welcome to this meeting of the babber
planning committee I will now ask the
governance officer to read out the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations thank you CLA thank you
chair please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you're in attending if
you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off and that your laptop is
also switched to silent I'd like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to be being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting Andor
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded if you hear the fire alarm
leave the building immediately bya fire
exit which is over towards the room
entrance make your way to the assembly
point which is iwit toown football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits do not enter the atrium
and do not re-enter the building until
told it is safe to do so thank you
chair thank you CLA some introductions
you just met CLA filot our governance
officer present is our chief planning
Officer Phil
Isbell um our legal advisor today is Ian
Dee and the case officer for the first
case is Sam
sumon are we happy if I can move on with
the agenda
okay apologies for absence and
substitutions thank you chair we have
apologies from councelor Jesse Carter
thank
you to receive Declarations of
disclosable pecuniary interests and
other registerable and non-reg interests
by members are there any to
declare may I Sherman um y just can I be
heard um we may not need to minute this
but I'm just going to say I think um
because it's can well both items we have
today are contentious matters obviously
but with reference to the Brett Vil
application councelor kurs Jane kurs has
quite properly discussed with me and
Governor's officers the fact that dead
and Vil Stow Valley um National
landscape partnership have made comments
on on it which are reported to you and
councelor kurs is on the board the
committee of that body I believe
appointed by this Council yes now that
that is an other reable interest an O
under the code but I have without going
into a lot of detail I've had a
discussion with councelor corz and I
have advised her that this in these
circumstances it's not a situation where
the code would require her to speak
because she's allowed to but then leave
the room and councelor KS has confirmed
that that she had no personal part in
deciding what that recommendation that
you see in your P how it was made and
that it wasn't discussed at any meeting
that she's been present at so in those
circumstance because it's a contentious
matter I thought it was appropriate we
say something I'll discuss with Mrs
philpop whether we put it in the minutes
we may may or may not need to but for
what it's worth there it
is nope all right Declarations of
lobbying are there any to
declare
no Declarations of personal site visits
are there any to
declare no thank you moving
on um BPL 2311 confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on November
the
29th are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these
minutes no in that case could I have a
proposal to accept the minutes Council
beer second councelor
osbor electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress councelor be thank
you
thank you members chair that's six votes
for and four abstentions that's carried
thank you thank you very
much sign in a
moment to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme non received
chair thank you site
inspections n requested chair none
requested okay in that case we'll move
on to the schedule of planning
applications the first one is
dc23
00740 the red line the street East Berg
gster essic I will now invite the case
officer Samantha Summers to introduce
the application to the committee what
your s
thank you chair good morning
members um this application seeks full
planning permission for the erection of
a storage building with two bed and
breakfast rooms above for the Red Lion
public house uh in East
bergal the erection of four dwellings
and alterations to the public car park
and replacement of the public
conveniences this application comes to
committee because it is considered to be
controversial
the red line shows the extent of the
application site and the blue line shows
the land which is in the ownership of
the
applicant the application site is within
the heart of the Village of East
beral this area is the historic core of
the village with a large amount of
listed buildings
the orange buildings are grade two
listed and uh includes a red line public
house and its immediate neighbors and
uh next door to that the red uh this red
building here is a grade two star listed
building The
Gables this area of East beral is also
within the conservation area defined by
the purple colored line the brown line
is the extent of the built up area
boundary the pink hatched area within
the orange line is the application
site members may wish to note uh that
part of the site is within the
conservation area and the builtup area
boundary but the southern part is in
neither the builtup area boundary
actually runs around three sides of that
southern part of the site just tucked in
here
this building here is a BT
building and this area of land here is
uh the village
Cemetery we have the uh Congregational
Church just here that building is
considered to be a non-designated
Heritage
asset this application is a resubmission
of a previous one
uh that came to committee for decision
on the 25th of January this year members
of the committee voted to refuse the
application on officer
recommendation that refusal is now being
uh appealed with the planning
inspectorate and a decision is due
imminently the scheme uh was the same as
today's application with the exception
of the number of dwellings and private
parking for the
dwellings the previous applications s
five dwellings within uh the PB Garden
the parking uh was the parking was
positioned uh in an area which would
impact the size and shape of the public
car park for East
bergal the public car park although
owned by the applicant has been on a
longterm lease to the parish council the
parish council has listed uh
the car park is an asset of community
value the car park is protected by
policy eb1 of the neighborhood plan and
also policy
lp28 of the
jlp the plan accompanied the application
uh for the asset of community value and
was subject to consultation with the
applicant at that time this is also the
area within the lease agreement with the
parish
council
in order to be able to build the
proposed five dwellings um and to have
uh the private parking that would be
Associated them with them in the beer
garden here that would be the private
parking with the previous
application
um this area that is shown as a wedge
which is currently part of the public
car park uh would actually become part
of the area for the private housing
that was considered to be contrary to
policy EB 11 of the neighborhood plan um
and therefore that was the reason for
refusal of the
application this is the current layout
of the site uh the Red Lion Pub and out
building which is used um as a shop is
positioned here that's the red R Lion
Pub just there um and you have the
gardens to the public house just
here Red Lion Cottage is located just
here uh that is actually in a separate
ownership this is the public Car Park
area and the public convenience building
is just
here the public car park is accessed
from the Main
Street
um and this also provides an access
through here to the BT building and also
an access point to the cemetery in this
corner of the site
here the car park currently has 30 32
Bays marked out for cars and two coach
Bays uh the co coach bays are uh
positioned in front of the public
conveniences just
here the beer garden sits between the
car park and the congregation ational
Church Congregational Church is
positioned here this is the P car
park although this area is a pleasant
Green Space it has no specific land
designation uh such as a visually
important space or is listed in the
neighborhood plan as a green
space this part of the site is not
within the conservation area or the
builtup area
boundary
there are three separate elements to
this application but are all linked by
this car parking area
here the first element is the erection
of a storage building within the grounds
of the public house with two bed and
breakfast rooms above that is located uh
in this area
here two additional parking spaces are
included uh just outside that building
which are not currently there so they
would be specifically for this
building the second element uh is the
erection of the four dwellings um in the
southern part of the site with
Associated car parking they're
positioned just here uh within the pub
within the pub Garden the third element
is the demolition of the public
conveniences and the erection of new
public
conveniences along with changes to the
layout of the car park
So currently uh the public convenience
building is here and it's proposed to
move it just up into this corner
here firstly we'll look at the storage
building with the bed and breakfast
rooms above the building would be on the
site of where a sh there is currently
sorry a uh a shipping container which is
used for storage in the car parking and
delivery area of the public house just
here um the building is proposed to
remove that storage container and put it
in a permanent
building this is the storage building
with the two bed and breakfast rooms
above much negotiation has taken place
uh between the Architects planners and
our heritage team as well as historic
England on the design and location of
the
building during the course of the
previous application and pre-application
prior to the submission of this
application that is uh when the
negotiations have taken place nothing
has changed since the previous
application came forward the design and
scale of all of the proposed buildings
uh were very important considerations
because of the sensitivities around the
Heritage assets being the conservation
area listed buildings and the
non-designated Heritage
assets the building has been carefully
designed to look like a traditional
outbuilding that would be Timber clad
with Clay panile roof the height of the
building has been kept to the same level
as the existing out
buildings um and windows have been
purposely kept to a minimum and a
small the building is important to the
viability of the public house and would
provide essential storage space to the
ground floor and visitor accommodation
to the first floor two bedrooms would be
provided uh with a double bed and on
Suite to each
room concerns have been raised about
overlooking of the private amenity space
of Red Lion
Cottage however the windows that look
out in that direction is a high level
window and is likely to cause is
unlikely to cause an overlooking issue
unless uh guests can actually stand on
the bed to look out of the window
yeah okay sorry I'll get a bit
closer both historic England and the
Heritage uh Team are content with the
design with the scale and the materials
of the building and do not consider that
it would harm any of the Heritage assets
the two car parking spaces would not
impact the current parking to the public
car park as these would be additional
car parking spaces
it is understood that the parish council
wished to further promote the village as
a center for the life and work of John
Constable this building would provide
important visitor accommodation in the
heart of the village it is likely that
visitors will spend money within the
village which in turn will help existing
businesses this is the access to the
public car park in the foreground is the
red mid line cottage uh with its out
building which is that creamy sort of
colored building just there uh both Red
Lion Cottage and the Red Lion Public
House are grade two listed and this part
of the site is within the conservation
area and builtup area
boundary The Gables which is grade two
star listed is set behind uh the brick
wall on the corner
here this is taken from the car park and
shows the location for the storage
building which would be next door to the
current shop building and behind uh the
garage building for Red Lion Cottage so
in this area just
here taking a few steps back um into the
car park uh the proposed building would
be cited uh in this location just here
the dominant structure would remain the
Red
Lion which is the tallest building in
the area which is
here the ridge height of the proposed
building would be much lower than the
existing Public
House this is the area uh that would
form the two additional parking spaces
one each side of the birch tree there
would be a loss of some of the shrubs
with in the
bed showing the access point uh with the
street with the red line complex on the
right hand side of the photo and shows
uh the differing roof levels around this
area of the
site this is an artist's impression of
how the proposed building would sit in
context with the surrounding
buildings
this element is considered acceptable as
it would support an existing business
and uh and provide uh security for the
jobs uh within the public house it also
provides important tourist accommodation
so you can just see uh the new storage
building with letting rooms above just
in this area
here the second element to the
application is the erection of the for
dwellings and the associated private car
parking for
them they're located just here in the
pub Pub
Garden at the moment the site is laid to
grass with some tree
planting the four dwellings would be
split into two sections two pairs of
semi- detached dwellings all four
dwellings would have two
bedrooms eight parking spaces are
provided and that that equates to two
for each dwelling uh which is compliant
with current parking
standards there would be a brick wall
between the existing uh public car park
and the private parking area uh to
Define what is private and what is
public
parking there would be an in andout
arrangement for uh vehicles moving in
and out of the AIS just here where the
current uh public convenience buildings
are and just here near the cemetery so
that Vehicles can maneuver
easily the development of this part of
site would result in the loss of uh some
trees but more trees are actually
proposed than are being taken
out a brick wall is also uh proposed
along the boundary with with the rest of
the beer garden uh to provide security
but also some uh sound
attenuation the area of this of this
this part of the site is actually
outside of the conservation area and
also outside of the builtup area
boundary the proposed dwellings are
considered to be of a very high standard
in terms of their design and the the
materials that are proposed for use they
very traditional in their design which
is acceptable in this sensitive location
within the setting of the conservation
area and within uh the setting of the
listed buildings and non-designated
Heritage
assets all four dwellings have two
bedrooms um and would be compliant with
building RS part
m43 uh which is for wheelchair
users this is an elevational drawing of
the brick wall uh which divides the car
parking zones and the beer garden from
the proposed residential development
again it's very traditional in its
design and the materials used English
Garden Wall Bond would be used to make
an attractive and traditional enclosure
for the site
these cross-sections show the proposed
Heights of the storage buildings and
dwellings uh compared to the existing
buildings on the site or near to the
site the top section uh shows the Red
Lion and red lion
Cottage uh along with the out building
the proposed storage building is shown
with the dotted
line um further along you have the
outline of the congregation or church
with the dwelling
the proposed buildings is subservient um
in scale to the existing are and are
acceptable in Heritage
terms moving on to some photographs uh
this is the front of the red line uh
with the beer garden that you can see
just through the gate there uh just at
the rear there would be where the
dwellings are
proposed this is looking at the side of
the red line
and the old mans is on the right hand
side just out of shot uh to the left is
the co-op store which also hosts the
post
office this is the front of the
Congregational Church the proposed
dwellings would sit behind the church um
there is a burial area in this area just
here this is the back section of the
church uh behind the church is the grass
area which forms the informal parking
for the church and behind this hedg line
is where the dwellings would be
positioned this photo shows the entrance
gates to the cemetery taken from the
Cemetery grounds the public car park
with public conveniences are located
just
here the Red Lion um is just at the back
here and this is the grass area where
the dwellings would be
positioned moving up the Cemetery Road
you can see the BT building that sits
outside the application site just on the
left of the photograph here the Red Lion
is the white building in the background
and the proposed dwellings uh would be
in this location
here this is the night for the four
dwellings the pair of semi detached
dwellings uh would be
positioned along here and along
here you can just see uh the corner of
the church the Congregational Church in
this location
here uh again a photograph of the uh
Congregational Church and uh just
showing the area in
context with the surrounding
buildings again just another view of
that
area and looking back um this shows the
public house here and its beer garden
and the dwellings would be positioned
here
this one shows the uh back of the
existing outbuilding that's used as a
shop um and it also shows that the pub
would still have significant grounds uh
to be used as a beer
garden as already mentioned most of the
application site is within the builtup
area of East beral however the section
where the dwellings are proposed is
outside of the builtup area therefore
this area is classed as Countryside in
the
jlp the site is considered to be well
located to the existing settlement with
the builtup area boundary on three sides
of it and it's just tucked in this tiny
little corner just
here policy spo3 of the jlp directs all
new development sites within settlement
boundaries unless they fall within the
criteria listed in table five of the
supporting text to the policy new
dwellings are not listed in table five
however the policies make some
exceptions for new dwellings in the
countryside one of the exceptions is
that they are in accordance with
policies in a made neighborhood
plan
SPO sorry policy SPO SPO
spo1 sorry getting my words wrong
requires that new Housing Development
should meet an identified need this is
explained in your table
papers eastberg has been subject of
three applications in recent years for
larger housing
developments all these sites are the
subject of extent planning permissions
and are anticipated to be bu built out
in the near
future the red star shows the Red Lion
site
the yellow stars are the three extent
permission
sites there is the site close to the Red
Lion just here uh which was a
development for 10 dwellings for
strictly over
55s that has now been built out to the
north is moors
Lane just
here this comprises 144 dwellings and
some business units and to the east of
the site uh is the heath Road
development sorry trying to get my
pointer to go where it needs to go uh
this one here uh that development is for
75 dwellings uh along with a shop
swimming pool
preschool it is unlikely
that that uh under uh policy
spo3 uh
sorry under
spo3 um sorry under spo1 we talk about
housing needs and the number of
dwellings that are required uh within
Baba for the plan
period um there was a housing needs
assessment that accompanied the
application that was actually
inconclusive as to whether a need in
eastberg was actually met by these four
dwellings that are
proposed
therefore we move on to the neighborhood
plan and also for districtwide need to
see what uh what their requirements are
there is a need both in eastberg alt and
uh districtwide for smaller two-bedroom
properties and also housing for older
people the adopted eastberg old
neighborhood plan is a much more
detailed document
that has policies detailing the type and
location of where new Housing
Development should be located within the
village it is already accepted that the
design scale and materials are
acceptable in terms of harm to the
Heritage and Landscape
assets policy eb2 of the neighborhood
plan seeks to have new development
within 800 meters of the village
heart the policy also puts a limit of 15
dwellings on proposed
developments this plan shows the extent
of the village heart that's included
within the neighborhood plan marked out
in blue the yellow star shows the
application site within the village
heart the scheme is for four dwellings
so less than the specified 15 dwellings
within the neighborhood
plan policy eb3 requires that small
scale development does not harm the
character and appearance of the conserv
cons a area nor adversely affects the
setting of The Heritage
assets development should reflect the
traditional scale form massing and
sighting of buildings in the area the
applicant has worked closely with both
historic England and the Heritage team
in house to design something appropriate
to the
setting they have found no
harm policy EB four of the neighborhood
plan seek specific details in terms of
housing type tenure and mix the policy
specifies that at least 40% of new
dwellings should be one and two
bedroomed
houses this scheme is 100% two bedroom
properties policy eb5 states that up to
onethird of new dwellings should meet
the need of older people and should be
within 4 100 MERS of the Parish Church
of St
Mary this area this plan actually shows
that area with the orange
circle the yellow star shows uh the site
in question which is well within that
400 meter buffer zone all of the
dwellings would be compliant with uh
building rigs for wheelchair user
homes these dwellings are considered
appropriate for old people that may wish
to downsize but stay in the village
without compromising the quality of the
homes that they move
to all facilities within the village
heart would be easily accessible by foot
or by motability
scooter when the jlp and neighborhood
plan are read together the departure
from from that policy of
spo1 about an identified need is
considered to be be acceptable because
of the districtwide need and also the
need that is identified within the
neighborhood
plan moving on to the final element of
the application and the part that links
everything together this part of the
presentation covers the car park it is
proposed to demolish the existing public
conveniences they are currently housing
this rather unattractive and uninviting
building the building does nothing in
terms of enhancing the conservation area
the brick type is a completely different
color to what is used around the area
which is mainly red brick um and also
the roof
tiles it is proposed to replace the
building with this much smaller um and
more sympathetically designed building
in another location on the site
this would result in the loss of uh
three
cubicles um and would only provide two
one for male one for female both would
be able to be used by wheelchair
users changes to the layout of the car
park um are also included in the
application the removal of one of the
flower beds and trees that sit within it
is proposed the new double uc's would be
located up in this corner near the
entrance to the BT
[Music]
building two important access points for
the BT building and also for the cemeter
would be would remain unobstructed at
all times there are currently 29
Standard Parking bays and three disabled
Bays with two marked coach Bays the
application does not seek to lose any
standard or disabled Bays but the new
layout only includes one coach parking
Bay this drawing shows the swep paths
for vehicle movements for larger vehicle
movements so you can see that things
like um bin trucks would be able to come
and empty bins from the dwellings and
move around the site
sensibly concerns have been raised by
the parish council that the new layout
removes one of the cge coach parking
Bays the architect has provided a
drawing showing the swep paths of the
coach Bays if two large vehicles are
parked together in the mark spase it
would appear that vehicles cannot
maneuver properly in the site this
drawing
um has been passed by uh highways for
consultation um and they agree that is
likely that Vehicles would find it
difficult to move in that area if both
parking Bays uh were filled at the same
time moving on to photographs of the car
park uh this photo is taken from the
access point to the BT building uh this
is the raised bed uh that would be
removed this area
here
um and this would be the location for
the public
conveniences this also shows the
Congregational Church in the background
here and where the new dwellings would
be
located this is looking into the access
for the Bett
building
uh
again another view um from the BT
building access looking back towards the
car parking
area this is uh the wall in the public
car park uh which is the boundary
between the grade two star listed
building um and uh the public car park
at the moment there is informal parking
along that area which would make it
extremely difficult for larger vehicles
to maneuver properly in that area it is
intended uh that there will be double
yellow lines along that area to make
sure that informal parking uh is
resisted and that uh people Park in the
marked
Bays again some more photographs of that
wall with the
gables just just showing some more
photographs of the car parking area this
is the access point uh to the cemetery
which would be kept clear at all times
so that people can access that
properly that's the hatching that is uh
currently there for the cemetery access
new dwellings would be behind this area
here and this is where the brick wall
would be built along that
boundary
this is from the cemeter just looking
back towards the car parking area you
can see the uh existing public
convenience building in this
area again just showing uh that very
long brick wall with the
gables and the access to be kept clear
for the BT building
that is the access to the BT building
and that's the building
itself this is the landscape plan uh for
the site it is proposed to resurface the
public car park with a more sensitive
material than the existing tarmac uh
that is considered to be an enhancement
to the conservation area the private
parking would be contained behind the
brick wall with some planting
uh that would have a different surface
material to uh help Define which is
private and which is public car
parking thank you for listening I know
that was a lot of slides to go through I
try not to make too many but I think in
this case it was quite important for
everyone to understand the site um it is
a complicated application there are
three elements to to this application if
members find that one element is not
acceptable then the whole application
will be
refused the application has addressed
the previous reason for refusal by
removing one dwelling so that all of the
private housing and parking can be
contained within the pub Garden the size
and shape of the public car park remains
unchanged the jlp supports businesses
and tourist facilities and therefore the
storage building with the uh letting
rooms above and changes to the car park
and improvements to the WC's is
considered
acceptable the proposed dwellings
although outside of the settlement do
fit the criteria of location and size
set out within the neighborhood plan
although the need the housing needs
assessment um is
inconclusive about the need for
additional housing in East bergal the
type of housing would provide a small
scale development of two bedroom
properties that have been identified as
a districtwide need therefore this
application is recommended for approval
subject to conditions required by
statutory consules and members have have
a copy of those conditions in a draft
decision notice should they wish to look
through for clarity thank
you I you
Sam pH thank you chairman if I may yes
just just quickly um we we have
suggested the language of the um draft
conditions that are on uh in your
recommendation in case members do wish
to get into fine detailed discussion
about the terminology of those there are
obviously a series of conditions
recommended uh I wouldn't propose that
we focus on those they are um to to a
large degree standard conditions from uh
our uh our um usual uh approach um and I
wouldn't I would suggest that the issue
is the uh the matter that needs interest
but for clarity chairman if uh members
wish to engage in discussion about the
conditions themselves we can go there
with that
document thank you
Phil any questions for the
officer councilor
beer yes perhaps you could just confirm
the uh toilet block is that in private
ownership uh I think refer to it as
public and if that's public who will
have the ongoing um concerns will it
belong to babber or who's responsible
for that afterwards thank
you the public conveniences I believe
belong to the applicant because it's on
his land however the parish council have
lease of the land and I believe that
they are responsible for cleaning and
closing
up the applicant has the freeold but
there's a lease to the parish council
okay thank you councelor
Wyman thank you chair could you confirm
uh is there any formal management of the
parking of the car park itself do we
have a facility in there where we manage
the actual process of parking you know
and people Park in the wrong place and
things like
that uh no it's a free car park and uh I
don't believe that there are anyone that
sort of looks around to make sure people
are parking properly
thank you councelor
grandon moph oh is working now um thank
you um could I have a look at I think it
was the last slide with the um diagram
on please I think it
was yes that's the one on CU that seemed
very clear and and easier to
see could you kindly I know you have
explained things really well but this
seemed to be quite an easy slide to see
everything could you please explain what
we're seeing here again please and also
remind me there were 29 park car parking
spaces originally could you please
remind me in the new um application how
many parking spaces that would be in the
new car
park okay so if I do the parking one
first so that I remember to do that uh
there's no loss of car parking the same
amount of spaces the only thing that is
changing um is there is a loss of a
coach parking Bay yeah so uh just to
explain two pairs of semi- detached
dwellings here and here and they're
Associated private parking just here
changes to the layout out of this car
park so that big bed uh just there will
be
removed um we have the storage building
with the letting rooms above just there
within you know the immediate
surroundings of the Red Lion and two
parking spaces provided extra parking
spaces for that
building was there anything else that
you wanted Clarity on um yes I've got
two other parts of the question if I may
please thank you um where is
the new or or where is the pub
garden and my so that's one question um
now and or on this plan and the parish
council talks about the car parking
spaces being the new car parking spaces
being very small is that the
case right so uh the pub car park sorry
the pub
Garden uh in is in this area just
here where oh right just here so they
have a big patio area just here um and
then grass area here that all that white
area yes thank you um and uh
the the car parking has actually been
passed by uh highways they did not have
any comment on that they were irregular
sized car parking bays at all so yeah
they seem to be fine I think thank you
very
much thank you councelor
Ma oh does work um thank thank you
chairman and um thank you uh Samantha
for this um I've got a few questions so
I'm asking to have a look at a few of
the slides if I may please um if we go
right back slide 10 you were talking
about the
windows um if we can have a look at
those
because there was a later photograph
that
showed different something different in
my opinion but if we have a look at that
one first
please it's really annoying the trouble
with so many
slides
right there you go okay right so so this
is the window that would be overlooking
the garden of red Lon Cottage right um
and you can see from these floor plans
that there is a bed in front of the
window and it is a high level window
it's not one that you would just you
know rest your hands on and look out you
would literally have to climb onto the
bed to look out the
window thank you thanks
um the next slide slide 11 I was I may
have missed it I'm sorry but um you do
lower your voice and we all do that
particularly when we're looking down and
I didn't understand the white building
behind the red line cottage what is that
that is in the ownership of Redline
Cottage and it's their garage building
so their garage would be in front of
what would be the new out building yeah
so it would sit just behind there okay
so that explains the I there is a draw
shall I bring up the drawing that shows
that the artist no no no it's fine
because there was a later um photograph
that showed a window sort of obscured by
that building so I was just trying to
work out what that was um slide 13
you're talking about a shop please
explain the shop please yeah so that's
this uh original out building to the
public house um I believe it was
probably used as storage previously um
and then it had a plan permission to be
turned into an antique shop and is it
still used as a shop I believe it is
still used as a shop yeah right okay
fine thank you um the next one is
17 sir you're shaking your head can you
confirm whether it's still a shop or
not there no long shop okay the
clarification thank
you um thank you um
my no I am there there
um my question about this in and out for
the new properties because knowing what
public nature is like they will see an
area and they'll Park in it is that due
to be gated the in and out
area uh no it's not due to be gated but
there is a high brick wall along here
right um the car parking is tucked in
here so I think it it does Define it
quite well and hides it from public view
okay fine thank than you and my last two
questions are um just general um you
talk about you mentioned graveyard and
then it went to cemetery I take it
that's an open Cemetery yes currently
currently used yes so there's two
there's a beral ground uh for the
Congregational
Church and then there is the open
Cemetery which is the the main one that
this relates to really because it's got
the access point to the cemetery okay
now this may not be in anyone's gift to
answer this the access to that cemetry
how is that defined
IE is that always going to be
open yes it will always be
open um and my very last question you'll
be very pleased to hear um is about um
the proposed four dwellings for
wheelchair users which I'm a great
believer in um we we all KN know need
because sadly things happen in life um
when we need extra space and perhaps the
use of a wheelchair however the bedrooms
are
upstairs so has there been any provision
for a stairlift to be put in permanently
to any of this or what has happened
about that
please uh that would fall under building
rigs um there is a condition should
members uh be minded to Grant permission
for this
uh that would uh that make sure that
they are all wheelchair user uh
dwellings I'm assuming I'm not an expert
on building rigs but I'm assuming that
staircases would make provision for a
stair uh lift to be available should
someone want to fit it I wouldn't
imagine that it would be done by the
developer at the time um but could be
added at a later
stage um thank you um I can't comment
further but thank you for asking
answering all my questions thank
you counc gron you have another question
thank you can I just have something
clarified then are these um new houses
specifically for
um um people who have accessible needs
or are they
General um
accommodation uh Market accommodation
for um but you're assuming they're
convenient for older people or people
with wheelchair needs could you tell me
what what the position is please yep
there's no condition to uh to make sure
that it is for older people um it will
just be open market open market housing
but built to a standard that an orderer
or wheel chair user could actually live
in Council register
[Music]
um it's concerning the car park uh you
you're remarking the car park the car
park will be remarked will be they be
remarked to wider levels than the
existing car park CU they look like they
were done in the 80s or whatever and
cars now wider so even though there's no
loss of car parking spaces are the car
parking spaces marked wider than they
are they would have been done in the
last century and the second is um what
is the is the surface of the the new
surface of the car park both permeable
and improves drainage to the uh car part
because I remember reading the the flood
report on the on the in the documents
and that seemed important and also they
re I noted that they re uh built the car
park to improve
drainage uh yeah so it's interesting
quite recently the parish council have
actually resurfaced that car park um and
marked the bays out so um I'm assuming
that they would be to current parking
standards uh this application seeks to
resurface the car park with um a more
sensitive material uh softer on the eye
um
and they would be the Baye would be
marked out to current parking standards
as well um in terms of the flooding
you're quite correct uh the environment
agency mapping does show that there is
some surface water issues on the site a
flood risk assessment was carried out
and also some modeling uh for future
events uh that was all passed by uh suff
County Council floods team uh and they
didn't have an issue with it
counc
KS thank you um it's concerning the um
coach parking in the car park I know
they the parish council have raised
issues with the loss of two bays to one
Bay um can you point out on the plan
where that is it looks as though it's at
the top am I right in thinking
that yeah so the the new coach parking
BAS would be just in this area
here thank you thank you and can I ask
one other quick question yeah of course
um where the residents car park would be
as you come through the car park I
assume there'll be signage at the
entrance there making it really clear
that it's residents only and not to park
in front of it and I can see there's W
lines but I assume there'll be signs
were they're saying private or residents
only or something we don't have that
detail as yet uh there is a condition
for um for landscaping which includes
signs um so any that come forward uh in
terms of private uh we we would have
control over exactly what they would
have because what we don't want to see
is something really unsightly within the
conservation area um so that would be
passed through our heritage
team
okay Council Brandon you want another
final question yes thank you um um if
I've understood it correctly one of the
main reasons for refusing the previous
um application was regarding the car
park please could you show us using the
diagrams what makes this application
regarding the car park acceptable
compared with the previous one which was
unacceptable could you show me why thank
you
sorry I'll just flick through
um so there was only one reason for
refusal on the previous application
however that was assessed against uh the
local plan and the course strategy so we
have reassessed the whole application uh
with the jlp so
cs11 was a nice policy that allowed
housing outside of uh settlement
boundaries the jlp has really tightened
up on that um so that's the reason there
was one reason for refusal previously
you know um so this area
here would be this the piece of land
that would have been sliced off if if it
was allowed with the previous
application because what this red line
here on the outside is the extent of the
public car park and what had happened is
because there were five dwellings which
needed 10 parking spaces they couldn't
squeeze it all into the public uh sorry
into the beer garden so what they had to
do was push it back into the public car
park and uh this wedge shaped piece just
here would have been missing from the
public car park
space what um the neighborhood plan plan
policy eb1 uh seeks to do is to retain
all of that car parking area um unless
it's offset somewhere else within uh the
village heart where further parking
could be provided bearing in mind this
is in the middle of the village it would
be really difficult to actually find
somewhere else for extra parking to go
that was Offroad uh to account for this
loss of land um and that's why wasn't
acceptable previously so what's happened
now is uh don't
know this is uh the existing car parking
line here with this beer garden and that
is all of the new
um yeah there you go that shows it all
of the housing and the parking spaces
are tucked into the beer garden and
doesn't overspill into the public Car
Park area
keeping it very simple is it because
there's been a reduction from five to
four that makes things so much easier
correct thank you I like it's
simple councelor bear was next following
on that um f of uh making Vin simple can
you tell me because we're re um
remodeling the whole car park is there
existing
um electric charge and vehicle
facilities uh there um and if there
isn't would they be able to put them in
I know that may be to the applicant um
because while you're digging it out and
remodeling it you could lay the the
frame workor there and also for the um
for dwellings um can there be electric
charging points put in there for them
because I think that's very valid
particularly if we're thinking that they
may maybe somebody turns up who's um
disabled or got a fehle like that they
would need that
facility thank you um I don't believe
and I'm sure uh Nigel will confirm this
one way or the other I don't believe
there are any EV charging
points um at the moment uh part of the
application would require EV parking uh
charging points uh that is contained
within the conditions of of an approval
in your list of conditions so they would
be sorry I didn't hear the last bit
because your voice dropped
sorry yeah so in your list of conditions
you'll see that there is a condition for
E
parking
yeah ccel
Davis I'm just
I
could uh yes there are Gardens for each
of the properties at the back of the
properties between the boundary uh and
the back of the
house and my question was around
housing
yes so there there is uh three
permissions in place uh you're quite
right the the attractive one the smaller
one for the over 55s that's already
being built out uh there's another one
that is being built out at the moment uh
David Wilson homes that is 144 dwellings
and then the one opposite the high
school on Heath Road that is for
75 that currently isn't being built out
they're still waiting to um deal with
their pre-commencement
conditions okay question
so there is a good mix of everything in
there uh one bedrooms up to four
bedrooms um lots of affordable housing
um so there is a good mix absolutely and
I think that's why it the housing needs
assessment was
inconclusive however when we're talking
about
spo1 in the jlp we're talking about
District wide
need um and small schemes like this the
mppf actually encourages smaller schemes
because they come forward more quickly
so the planning permissions uh for the
big ones in eastberg all the 144 and the
75 they've taken years to get to where
they are already so they're not actually
delivering the houses quickly even
though the planning permissions are in
place and because we have to count the
number of houses each year to keep our
5year lands Supply these smaller sites
are very helpful in providing extra
numbers for us to make sure that we're
hitting our
targets thank
you no in that case thank you Sam we're
going to have to take a break because
apparently a number of the microphones
just aren't working which means we
nothing can be recorded from the
microphones either so
session
um fine
we absolutely no more questions to the
planning officer no okay moving on
public
speakers um I understand Nigel Roberts
is going to speak on behalf of the
parish council you have three minutes to
address the panel thank you very
much thank you good morning I'm Niger
Roberts Town planner and vice chair at
East bergal Parish Council today I will
reinforce my council's serious
objections to this application my focus
will be on policy considerations where I
believe the case officers conclusions
are misleading at best the application
involves four Market houses outside the
berter Perry boundary on on a landlocked
Garden
site this is contrary to Neighborhood
plan policies EB 1 2 and three no
need not affordable homes and backland
development the principle of development
is also not acceptable under new local
plan policy
spo3 and policy lp1 for sites outside
the builtup area boundary these are
recently adopted policies and clearly
mean that these four houses are not
justified there is also no basis to
allege any exceptional case in East
burgal we have 229 houses under
construction more than twice the
evidence needs for 15 years there is no
policy justification to permit any more
especially on this sensitive site the
case Officer says the points at issue
with this application are the car and
Coach Park
this would be the
case but only if you accept the four
houses as
given the car park new layout is only
needed to provide access to the new
housing without the houses there's no
need to make any changes to the car and
Coach Park but let's consider the
consequences anyway the proposals will
rip up an existing
facility only rebuilt two years ago at 8
000 cost to the public purse it would
demolish a public toilet block with a
net loss of five toilets not three it
will create an inferior layout with
smaller spaces and the loss of one coach
parking Bay and it will position the
smaller toilet unit and three car
parking spaces so they block the right
of way to the cemetery So the plan is
not even achievable and you'll see this
on the map that has been provided by the
Parish Council in your papers these
policies are contrary to the new local
plan policy lp28 which prohibits
development involving any loss of
existing Community facilities and here
we have just that these proposals also
still ride rough shot over the
neighborhood plan policy ep1 which
safeguards this car park so today for
you councelors the question must be is
this application policy
compliant are the houses and carpot
proposals in line with B's development
plan policies and the answer is I
believe demonstrably no and on the
substantive planning issues this
application fails it cannot be justified
by either local plan or Napal plan
policies and neither are the proposals
practicably
implementable sit there and we'll see if
anybody wants to ask you some questions
any questions for the
speaker coun
cron thank you thank you chair um can I
ask whether you know how often um two
two coach parking places are needed in
the village please you know do they do
do both car park do both spaces
sometimes get used at the same time they
do and I I should say it's not always
for coaches and so large uh delivery
lores servicing uh the Village also use
those spaces and they're an important
facility so sometimes we may have a
coach and a Lori times we might have a
coach and a and a car um but the there
there is certainly a need for two and
there there's been two in existence for
decades any more questions for the
speaker thank you very
much
the committee you have three minutes
thank you thank you for hearing me I'm
here to support the parish council as as
hard as I possibly can we need our car
parking spaces left as they are and we
need our five toilet
spaces it's used not only by outflung
villagers coming into the center of the
village but also
Traders all sorts of people ring by
coach first place of stop over is the
toilets of course we need the five it
may not look pretty as your speaker says
but it's functional and it can be
improved um I wrote to every single
District counselor in April 8th of April
2023 now I gather there's been might
have been a change you might not have
had my letter but I took the trouble to
write to each and every one of you
separately because I think it's so
important to our village uh you've heard
that we are having another 230 basically
houses being built we need Extra Spaces
not less
um uh in the 1980s bayird District
councilors your
predecessors had the enlightened Vision
to rent and control of the current car
park even build building the much needed
toilets in the Village Center how many
villages do you know that has toilets
facility in their Village nowadays not
many are left we still have a post
office we need our parking we need we do
not need the building we have a lot of
building coming and we we absolutely do
know not know where to put them as it
is the the parish council um are also um
have trying to use the Congregational
Church which with which you will
probably be aware um for forthcoming
plans for the um for it um parking will
be needed St Mary's Church with pews
remov to allow better seating for large
community space to be available to the
community where will all these people
Park um we have a lovely little village
which Baba District councilors foresaw
and had the vision to see and help us
I'm asking you to not change that
facility and do not allow these
buildings to be built
um at the moment our our Pub is no
longer a pub um unfortunately it should
be
buzzing um it's it's not uh the coin to
coin a phrase the lights are on nobody's
in um
it it's a lot of our communities do not
like what is happening um and do not
want these houses built they may not be
here today but I know they're behind us
and they're behind our Parish
Council thank
you thank you so I don't know if I
understood you correctly there is the
pub an active operating pub at the
moment not so not a pub as we know it um
any longer it's not frequented by local
residents
basically it it now becomes a pub for
out out um well-off people coming to the
Village um and and that unfortunately is
the case it's no longer where you go and
have a a p of beer
but is it's open as a pu um I'm not
quite sure what what you would call its
title nowadays I'm afraid um as
what thank you thank you sorry anyway
councelor beer thank you well it's over
a pub or it's not um but my question is
um the toilet block was explained quite
clearly to me by our officer who didn't
excellent
presentation um belongs is leased by the
parish council correct who owns the car
park as is that is that the property of
the public house as far as I know it is
but we have a lease over
it a long
lease
presman thank you chair sort of a joint
question if I may to both the Paris
Council and the objetive please um you
talked about the you know the the
village and how you uh you're involved
in tourism and all the other various
things and the heritage is there any
intention on the part of the Paris
Council and all the Civic Community to
improve the facilities around the car
park and actually sort of you know
engage perhaps with the Caravan Club for
overnight parking or whatever you know
just to actually improve the actual
facility and also the issues relating to
the toilet uh obviously it's down from
sort of five spaces down Sorry Seven
down to two um is that within as as the
parish council hold the lease to the car
park is that permissible within the
terms of the
lease
um would would you like the parish
counselor to answer that question rather
than myself certainly we need we need
the uh toilet block I know it's not f f
but it's functional and it can be
improved um there yeah I think there are
two there are two questions um the first
one uh is the parish council keing to
maintain and improve the facility uh the
answer that is yes which is why we spent
£80,000 of public funds on on doing just
that only two years ago so we totally
resurface the
carp um we relined it uh and we maintain
all the um the the the soft landscape
around it uh and we we have a
contractors who come in regularly to um
to maintain that uh and we see that we
see it as a an important facility for
the Village um a necessary facility for
as a tourist facility as well um and an
equally as Joyce has said the the toilet
block is very important for tourists and
for Coach parties um and the coach
parties turning up um are much better
served with seven public toilets than
they are with
two um inevitably in relation to the uh
does the lease provide well the Le we we
have a 20-year lease of which we have 12
years Parish Council has 12 years um for
it to run um uh the after that the the
the the uh Freeholder uh langum property
development company company um would be
assuming the lease doesn't roll over to
the parish council if if he were to take
the lease back if they were to take
lease back then I they would be able I
presume to um do what they wished with
it but
um who knows what might happen at the
end of 12 Years thank
you councel
KES
um yes um I assume that for the cemetery
that that that people would park in that
car park to use the cemetery and also is
there another car park in East bergo in
the center I'm not aware that there is
but I don't know it that work no I mean
parking is is very difficult in in in
the center the over spill from that car
park um um has to park or it chooses to
park on what we call the street with a
very narrow Bend running around to St
Mary's Church and uh and with the shop
and as s pointed out the carp is uh it's
very congested and it's very dangerous
um and there is no other car parking we
we we as a parish council we're very
concerned because with another probably
somewhere between Mr chairman on a point
of order and clarification the question
was to the objector we're now going
through um the parish cancel again and I
don't think that's fair unless you're
going to let the applicants have the
same sort of um time
addition
C Brothers exactly who are you asking
the question to um either of them really
whoever could answer am I not allowed to
do that
sorry okay hang on
sorry I think I think we're in the
situation has councelor K has had a
satisfactory answer to her question yeah
but I think we can let it rest
there have you effect your answer yes
right thank you thank you very much
thank
you
C you going to ask question thank you
chair may ask a question to the parish
council
please am I mayor hang hang
on yeah we allow at this time thank
you
um in in the paper or or in your
objections you talk about the size of
the parking Bays compared in the
application compared with the existing
parking Bays you say that they're
smaller have you measured them and B do
you know how much smaller they are or
can you tell me about this please um I
don't have the the the detail of that
but um when the car park was reely re
was relined two years ago um we were
aware that cars today are much larger
than they were 20 or 30 years
prior in order to address that we made
sure that the the spaces were each at an
angle so cars could easily maneuver
in and we increase the
width if you look at the plan the the
the I think I think you've answered the
question have you got a satisfactory
answer Catherine thank you very
much
speaker no in that case we'll move on we
have nobody to speak on behalf of the
application but we do have the agent
present you sir have three minutes to
address the committee thank you uh just
appoint of clarification I'm the
planning consultant appointed rather
than the uh the planning agent um good
morning members thank you for the
opportunity to speak in support of the
application noting the detailed
committee report prepared by your
officers and the reasoned
recommendations set out therein I'll
Focus my attention on the broader
planning merits of the
scheme through the provision of the
storage building and B&B rooms The
Proposal was serve to support the
operations of the red line Public House
and in turn contribute to the present
and future VI ability of the pub a
significant source of employment within
East bold there is a demand for tourist
accommodation locally to which the
proposed rooms will contribute whilst
also serving to diversify the
accommodation offering within the area
in these regards through the support of
the local economy the scheme will
provide T tangible economic
benefits the development makes provision
for the replacement of existing toilet
facilities located with the red line car
park the facilities are considered to be
of a higher quality than the existing as
the design of the building they
contained within is more sympathetic to
its setting the red line car park itself
is retained by The
Proposal the housing element of the
application will deliver four additional
dwellings immediately adjacent to the
east berol builtup area boundary and
within the village heart an accessible
location for occupies of the development
serving to support local service and
facilities and promote the use of
sustainable modes of Transport the mix
size and type of housing proposed is
considered to respond positively to to
the desire for smaller units and housing
for older people expressed within the
East beral neighborhood
plan the proposed scheme has been
formulated with great weight for to the
conservation and where possible the
enhancement of the landscape and Scenic
beauty of the OMB this equally true with
regards to the conservation and of the
significance of
surrounding surrounding designated and
non-designated Heritage assets through
its high quality and sympathetic design
The Proposal integrates
positively with the character of the
era
sorry this is equally true with regards
to the conservation of the significance
of surrounding designated and
non-designated Heritage assets through
its high quality and sympathetic design
The Proposal integrates positively with
the character of the area whilst
reinforcing local distinctiveness no
harm to the OM or Heritage assets would
arise to conclude the proposal is in
accordance with the development plan
when taken as a whole furthermore the
development will comply with the mppf
the benefits presented by the
development are significant and will not
be outweighed by any measure by any
identifiable adverse impacts of which we
consider there to be none we therefore
respectfully ask members to approve this
application in accordance with the
officer's recommendation thank you very
much thank you any questions for the
consultant councelor beer uh yes I just
asked on the um the for the electric
charging points um they are available to
the uh four new dwellings I gather um
will you be speaking to people who are
redor the car park and saying whether
they can put in the facilities for Ev if
they so wanted to do at a later date cu
once you're digging up a car park you
want to put in pipes and all sorts of
things so you don't have to dig it up
again uh thank you um to confirm so
obviously we're we're proposing EV
charging points within the uh the car
park serving the dwellings um obviously
the conditions will pick up that detail
um we've also just been confirmed that
there's three EV charging points
proposed within the actual car park
itself thanc hold could you confirm um
that the right of way to the cemetery
will not be blocked in any way
whatsoever it appears we have had some
contradicting comments it appears on the
mapping we saw they weren't but can you
confirm that they won't that access will
not be
blocked
and the other point I was going to make
was there is no loss of parking spaces
is there in this plan can you confirm
that
uh just a point of clarification
obviously I'm here to talk about
specific planning related matters um in
terms of private rights and private law
it's not something that I I can
obviously go into detail over um in
terms of the public rights of way
there's no public rights of way within
the site that will be impeded um further
sorry I mean access to the cemetery as a
public
rway uh there will be access to the
cemetery via the the public car
park
sorry there I believe there was a second
question second question Council
H was could he confirm there'll be no
loss of parking
spaces uh so in terms of the officer
report sets out that there will be
effectively um one uh coach Bay that
will be will be lost in effect um
obviously there's further information
that's been provided around the
functionality of that coach Bay um and
the officer has obviously gone through
an exercise of uh explaining why that
the scheme is
acceptable thank
you Council
grandon thank you um the parish council
were unable to say whether the new
proposed Bays parking Bays were
smaller or compare comparing the size
are are the
new the bays in the
application smaller than the existing
parking Baye please car parking BAS
uh I I don't actually know what the size
of the existing bays are um in terms of
what I can comment on is the fact that
the proposed parking bays are designed
to meet uh sub County Council guidance
um so they ask S to meet the standard
specifications that the parking Bays
required to meet
today thank you councelor holms you want
to come Council register you go
first
I'm trying to get one working this one's
working
um uh where was I right yeah just some
clarification what is the rationale
between reducing the number of toilets
from five or seven depending on how you
count them uh down to two accessible
toilets uh given that you you've already
recognizing that you've got coaches
arriving coaches which carry 40 people
um most of which may well be urgent
requirement of a toilet and I don't
understand the logic of that um if you
could explain
please uh in terms of the building
itself obviously there's there's been a
lot of work put into designing something
that's sensitive um to the setting um in
terms of its size and design being of
high quality um so I believe in terms of
the design of the building a lot of that
was derived from the the sensitivity of
the setting um within that building that
was was designed obviously two cubicles
have been identified um they're
obviously uh wheelchair accessible um so
in terms of the rationale I think it's
largely derived from from a you know a
design response really um whilst also
trying to provide facilities that that c
for the local
community C hold just one other thing is
yellow lines has been mentioned um I
think one of the councils mentioned
there on the drawings one of the
drawings but actually who if anyone
would be applying to have the Y lines
applied within the car par perimeter
would it be the applicant would it be
the parish council because that has to
go through I believe the County Council
and it's not something that is easily
given I believe so who would take that
upon themselves to apply for yellow
lines uh I suppose slightly falling
outside of my expertise here but um in
terms of the fact the car park is
privately owned um um from my point of
view that the County Council aren't
effectively the body responsible for
demarking those that the yellow lines so
um I believe that would be something for
the for the applicant obviously if they
were delivering the development that
they would they would seek to provide
those
lines okay no more questions thank you
very much
oh sitting up there I can't see
you councelor Davis ask you
question it's onent um two questions I
note you've got heat pumps in the design
which is great um I didn't see any
mention of PV panels or solar panels are
they
included uh but at this stage there was
there was no nothing included I think
given get the set the setting and
basically obviously um Conservation Area
status a andb etc um in terms of the
methods that we incorporated was Tred to
I suppose balance out sustainability
credentials versus also um you know high
quality design so um at this moment time
no there are no solar panels being
proposed through the application okay
thank you the second question um is you
mentioned that these houses would be
suitable for older people can you
explain what it is about the design that
makes it suitable for you know our older
residents um I'm going to defer to the
to the uh the architect who's here just
to answer that question if that's
okay so the houses are designed for the
open market but they are designed sorry
can you speak up the houses are designed
for the open market but they're suitable
for elderly residents in so much as the
ground floor laboratory can be uh the
ground floor laboratory can converted
into a bathroom so that um a bedroom
could be positioned on the ground floor
so that uh it could be uh occupied on
one
level it could also have um a knockout
panel Incorporated for a lift um the
building's a timber frame and that would
be quite straightforward to
do thank
you counc
KS um hello just just going back to the
car park and the double yellow line
um who would enforce that would that I
mean do car park the car park free isn't
it so I don't know if anybody goes
around there checking it but if there
are W lines if motorists did park on the
W lines blocking the access to say the
the houses would there be anybody going
around to enforce that and to ticket
them or ask them to move that might be
beyond your scope I don't
know um I suppose what I can comment is
it's probably exactly the same same
scenario things are presently um I
appreciate they'll have the other
component of of the housing and and
access um I suppose with any Housing
Development where um it's not adopted
Highway um and it's enforced by sort of
I suppose private law or you know
regarding access and and rights of
access so effectively I suppose it would
would would have to place itself or
outside of the the planning process of
other sorts of regulations
really thank
you no thank you very much I think
you're getting away this
time we have
next the ward member councelor S Davis
you have five minutes to address the
committee good morning counselors um
first of all on the matter of um the
reduction of car parking spaces we think
there will be a reduction of car parking
spaces because what's not been mentioned
At All by the officer is there is a
right of way along the car park and
along the back that is the right of way
to the cemetery on that at the moment is
the new toilet and some car parking
spaces so we think this actual scheme
can't be put into place without reducing
the car parking because there's a right
of way that may not be a planning matter
but there is a right of way there but
the problem with this application is
that it breaches eastberg 's
neighborhood plan the officer accepts
this when she says the proposal overall
is not completely policy
compliant and then goes on to recommend
approval but hey it's only a
neighborhood plan so here's how it
doesn't comply with our neighborhood
plan there is no housing need um we've
alluded to an assessment um a housing
assessment that was in the papers that
appears to have been done by the
applicants agent we have 144 houses
proceeding at pay Inbal the 75 on a site
that's already cleared that's going to
be proed proceeding at PACE quite soon
we've got 10 already built to suggest
we're not meeting our housing need is
incorrect and in fact The Joint local
plan lp1 at 1303 specifically says
windfall infill developments is not
considered necessary to meet
districtwide need so when the officer
says that these houses are going to help
to meet the district need no lp1 says it
is not necessary
ep2 states that affordable houses on
sites outside or adjacent to the builtup
area boundary will be encouraged not
speculative Market homes these houses
are not affordable housing and they sit
outside the
bab they do not comply with eb2 and we
strongly reject the office's assertion
that they
do ep5 seeks to increase the housing
options for El elderly people explicitly
for elderly people if development takes
place near the Village Center these
houses have steep stairs the bedrooms
are upstairs and the wholly unconvincing
explanation by the architect of how it
could be um adapted was unconvincing
they're not designed for the elderly eb5
our neighborhood plan was quite specific
that we wanted to encourage in if
anything takes place in the Village
Center it should be for elderly people
and these are
not so the application breaches several
policies of the eastberg alt
neighborhood plan the recommendation to
approve is therefore irrational because
they have not taken this factor into
account we ask the committee not to ride
rough shod over the eastberg old
neighborhood plan because if this
application is approved what message
does that send to the communities with
adopted or emerging neighborhood plans
the message is don't bother you've been
led to to believe that you can shape
your communities and have a stronger
Voice through neighborhood plans but as
this report shows planning officers will
discard your neighborhood plan if it
suits them that is why it is so
important that the planning committee
gives our neighborhood plan its proper
weight and rejects this application
thank
you thank you just for clarification how
old is your neighborhood plan it was
formed in
2016 and we're renewing it now we're
reviewing it thank you I also like the
the planning offic to clarify
lp1 to make sure members
are thank you chairman if I may yes just
for clarity lp1 refers to wind fill
infill housing outside settlement
boundaries that term is expressly
defined in a footnote as the filling of
a small undeveloped plot in an otherwise
builtup Highway Frontage your officers
don't consider this is a small
undeveloped plot in an otherwise builtup
Highway Frontage thank you chairman
thank
you any questions for the ward
member councel hold how many of these
houses that you mentioned that have got
commissional being built are within the
800 meters of the village
heart yeah there's 10 the 10 that are
already built they're specifically for
over
55s um and with a lifetime sort of
condition on that they're the only ones
within 800 meters of the center of the
village thank
you anyone
else
no
oh c Council gr and go on thank you
thank you chair um do you know how many
of the planned
um um application um
buil um developments that are being
built um include two bedroom how many
two bedroom properties are included in
the applications coming up what the ones
already being buil at the moment
um approximately
be 30 or 40 we think we yeah I mean the
majority of them are three bedrooms and
above we think there's about
30 um one and two bedroom
homes thank
you thank you councelor
Davis
right I'll Now open up for debate would
anybody like to kick off any
comments councel H go on right I'll
start um thank you to everyone who's
spoken I think we've got an overview of
of two different views on a on an
application that's before us um
certainly the ward member is quite
contradictory to the plan and officer
and a lot of policies that are referred
to in the East berot neighborhood plan
certainly when I look through the
neighborhood plan I can see that um they
comply a sort of that interpretation
really isn't it um and I can see that
certainly eb2 it
complies um I also when I look at eb3 I
can see compliance compliance EB4
eb5 um
and I appreciate that perhaps the Paris
Council thinks this development is one
step too far but when I read through the
neighborhood plan and you you almost say
that the officers aren't respecting it
and appreciating it but through my view
reading of it I can see
compliance
um so it's a difficult one because I do
agree with you that neighborhood plan
should be taken and given full weight as
as as is directed but perhaps in this
situation in this this case the wording
of this particular neighborhood plan is
somewhat open to this type of
development and scheme coming forward
which you may regret um as if it is
given permission then you may wish to go
back and and try and narrow that down
but looking at the viability side of
things the public
house um having to
bnbs um to help it enable it to succeed
and and perhaps move forward and become
more popular within the
village the tourism side of things is
the economy the local economy um
everything sort of ticks a lot of boxes
the car park there isn't a reduction in
in spaces you've lost one coach Bay
which I accept everyone accepts um the
toilet block is reduced um from from
seven to
two so there is a loss of toilet um
immunity there
but
overall I can't
find the one or two negatives in this
outweigh the
overall um compliance with policy and
the need to help a local business and
help tourism in what which is a very
popular tourism spot
so I can't really find a policy issue at
the moment to go against the officer's
recommendation but I'm Keen to listen to
other members to see and gather their
thoughts and I'll have the option to
come back
later thank you CC
beer thank you very much Mr chairman um
yes well I fully concur with my
colleague behind me um we've listened to
uh a good um report from our plan plan
and officer uh who is the expert on this
sort of in and whilst none of us like to
believe that they're the experts and I
for one would be one of the first to say
well they don't always get it right I on
this occasion you've done exceedingly
well um backland development was
commented by somebody earlier on uh that
went out the window years ago um now you
can build on backland that happens in my
Village all the time unfortunately and
um you you've got to have a real strong
case to stop it but it certainly isn't
like it used to be where you could just
say backl development don't give it
approval it's not like that at all
nowadays we have to be flexible we have
to listen to the pros and cons um you've
mentioned yellow lines now I can tell
you that that's the responsibility of
suff County Council but the town or
Parish Council can request yellow
allines on
highways this is private property uh so
they certainly wouldn't put yellow lines
onto it but there's nothing stopping the
parish council oh sorry and to get
yellow lines if the town or Parish
Council wants them and the local County
Council supports this they can happen
quite quickly still two years to get
them um the uh if it's uh private
property then you need to get a private
uh firm that would manage the car part
but then somebody has to pay for that so
that's the other bit um listening to a
lot of the comments and listening to my
colleague behind me I think that um I'm
completely satisfied uh and I would like
to recommend this the officer's
recommendation and I look for ask you to
ask for a second thank you thank you so
that's proposer do I have a second for
the
motion councelor hul do you want to
speak now or speak
later thank you than be can you turn
your microphone off since we're having
fun again any other comments from anyone
else councilor Mary um thank you Mr
chairman um well being award member for
laam which is one of the busiest tourist
spots in our district
um a few comments I
think um East beral are probably very
very fortunate that they have a private
landlord for a car park who certainly
don't have one of those in
Len um and I am it could I I could
suggest I'm really surprised that the
parish council have not tried to
purchase their own land for car park if
they are so concerned about all of this
um this is is not getting away for the
fact that um car parking is probably
needed within the parish um laam also
redid their um public laboratory blocks
and have reduced them considerably to
and these are unisex actually but to
larger um
facilities um because I could suggest
being a very tall
lady um the normal size of public
Laboratories are very
constricting and I've in the past have
had to stand on a labatory to be able to
shut the door so I think any um upgrade
of laves is a really good idea but laven
also reduced their number
considerably um by about 60% so they too
have fewer but it
works um but they also have far more far
more visitors
I have commented about um the
disabled facilities in these properties
and I understand what the architect is
um is saying because moving to homes for
what we call for the whole of Life are
always a good idea not withstanding the
fact that perhaps a wheelchair user
would need um a lift or a stair lift to
access the um bedrooms upstairs it is
actually recommended for older people to
actually use stairs because they're good
for us and I'm going to say
us if you use enough stairs it does help
your Fitness
considerably um I agree with um with two
of my colleagues here that
the officers recommendation um is the
right one for this case thank
you thank you councilor ma there anybody
else who wants
to councelor
Wyman thank you chair um it's been a
really interesting sort of session
listen to all of it this morning I think
we all appreciate the input that
everyone's made to both the you know the
application itself the the officers
details and also the input everyone's
made um personally I feel conflicted
because there seems to be quite a lot of
contradiction between our new jlp
policies and the somewhat probably
slightly more out ofd um East bergal uh
neighborhood plan um I was particularly
moved by Council Davis's comments on the
neighborhood planning process and how
that could easily psychologically Dent
uh communities from enter into the the
whole thing really but having uh regard
Council H's comments on the date and
Inception of the um neighborhood plan it
does mean that potentially they may
ought to spend a little time trying to
improve it
um it's a really difficult decision but
I feel minded to consider the issues
over the windfall um issues relating to
the houses
the there could be a situation
potentially where you might imagine that
the uh the applicant might like to
restrict the age of ownership to over
55s which would be probably far more
acceptable to the SP go Parish Council
um other than that chair um I feel
minded to
um refuse or go against the
application thank you any more comments
councelor
Davis
got it excellent um I agree with
councelor Wyman it's it's quite quite a
finely balanced judgment and the idea of
going against a neighborhood plan is
anathema to me and we've just had our
own neighborhood plan made last month so
we're hoping it will you know influence
decisions and I know this is slightly
older but you know it still carries
carries weight um in terms of the
policies I mean spo3 talks about the
sustainable location of new development
um this isn't a site that's allocated
for development it does say it has to be
in accordance with a made neighborhood
plan but we know we're being told by the
experts on the neighborhood plan because
they wrote it that it is not in
accordance with it so that kind
of brings some reservations in for me um
I'm also don't like the fact it's
outside the build up boundary I know
it's right next to it but I also thought
that with developments that were outside
a builtup area boundary it really had to
be a rural exception site which then had
housing that had particular categories
like it was protected for local use
so I'm still slightly on the fence so if
any of the other counselors can clarify
my thinking for me I would be
grateful Phil do you want to
um well chairman I'm not one of the
counselors perhaps if I come come back
later on there's bit I thought clarify
something for
me chairman I can I mean I think I think
it's fair to say that between ourselves
and the parish council and with all due
respect to
counselors we disagree that we're not
complying with the naal plan but that is
fundamental to this and I think what
this committee is here to do is to apply
the policies not try and interpret them
creatively we have to take the ordinary
natur meaning of these words and apply
them and I think if you take for
instance eb3 as as one policy about
backland development it it says backland
development won't be supported in two
circumstances developments that affect
the character of conservation era
setting and listed buildings it doesn't
tell you about backland development
other than that
so in terms of that assumption that one
is breaching the neighborhood plan and I
respect Mr Roberts and he and I have
discussed planning matters and agreed
and disagreed in the past asked um we
are not here to try and interpret the
policies we have to apply the things as
they're written and as they're written I
think we take the view the development
complies with the basket of policies
there will almost in every case be some
policy you breach it's almost inevitable
but in this instance we take that basket
of policies your joint local plan your
neighborhood plan and we think the
development compliance thank you
chairman thank you um having a war where
I have a number and my colleague over
there we have a number of villages
involved with with neighborhood plans
some that have been in place for as long
as the burgo one but it's being updated
and they're treating it as a living
document
not a monument set in stone and maybe
that's what the problem may be here that
we've got legislation that's coming
through um recently in 2023 and we're
trying to relate it back something six
years
ago thank
you was it canel gron you wanted
to yes thank you um yes I'm I'm having
great difficulty coming to a decision
because it is so finely balanced and in
fact what I had been planning to do was
request an officer um explanation of how
they came to that balance if it was
allowed and partly um philis Bell has
has explained that um I don't know if
it's possible anymore to explain how how
the balance was achieved you know that
you've come to the decision that you
have with with the waiting the you know
the waiting of the um different aspects
is that at all possible to request that
um
chair or or have we gone past that um
let's just check whether the chief
planning officer can do something for us
yes thank you chairman I i' i' I'd be
tempted to say um the committee report
is that balancing in detail um I
think I guess I guess I would say that
wouldn't
I I think the the JP is quite clear
about development outside the settlement
boundary but it does then reference on
the neighborhood plan and so you've got
to read both together you can't read one
on its own and the policies of the
neighborhood plan take you into the EB
policies and eb1 is is is a minimum and
that question of need I think this
question of departure which I I think
councilor Davis referred to at the
beginning um we acknowledge that we may
not be in a perfect situation around uh
SPO uh one spo3 and and that question of
need but there is information around
need and I think if there is a departure
it is not significant enough to alter
the overall balance of what you have in
this
um and know I'm conscious that you the
parish have made a very forceful
statement of their uh thoughts about
this and they will probably you know
strongly disagree with me but you know
eb1 uses Words which talk about a
minimum of new homes and it says nothing
else about that it simply says a minimum
of 86 new homes and that presumably is
in in in Parliament a floor not a
ceiling and here we are we must make
make of it what we will there are other
policies in the the bural neighborhood
plan
I I talked about eb3 and I think you
know that has been mentioned and that
has specific criteria and this is where
you end up going with this so from my
point of view there is a balance to be
drawn there are some elements of some
parts of the policies in in the JP that
and this relates to the need question
which I think we don't have an answer to
because the needs assessment was
inconclusive as Sam has already
described at length um you know there
you're then into what else you have
within the neighborhood plan for
instance
uh and I think it's eb1 is the car
parking plan sorry the car parking
policy and that looks to to to safeguard
uh this car park and was the meat and
drink of the earlier decision and our
our view is is that this application
does achieve that planning committee is
there to to look at differences of
opinion and what can I say but here we
are our our conclusion is that you know
taking all of this application on its
own merits we think that the
neighborhood plan is not being trampled
upon we think that the joint local plan
is being complied with there are
elements of this basket of policies that
are not complied I talk about need as an
element but in the end you know we take
the view that the balance goes in favor
to talk about weight individually will
be a very long conversation which I
think Sam tried to do it's written in
the report it' be wrong for me to try
and rewrite this in this
presentation thank you councelor kades
you were
next thank you chair
um I'd like to Echo councelor Davis's
thoughts about this it is this is really
really difficult um I can see that the
um there's clearly a need for storage
and holiday accommodation on the site
and there doesn't seem to be any issue
with that however with the housing
developments there are already a lot of
houses coming forward in East beral and
it seems as though there's quite a lot
of two-bedroom houses being planned so
maybe they don't need anymore um for me
the issue is with the car park and the
loss of coach parking and knowing how
important you know the tourism is in
eastberg hle if you've only got one
Coach Park parking space and fewer L um
it doesn't help does it you know it's a
shame it's a real shame that it's you
have to take it all as one rather than
if it was separated then it would you
know but you do have to take it as one
one
application um so that's all I'm saying
really thank you although you may want
to have listened to
um councelor ma telling you how well it
had work reducing the number of toilets
in
labin anyway councilor maor you wanted
to to join in you see I listen to some
of your Pearls of Wisdom thank you very
thank you thank you very much I think
I'm an expert on public Laboratories
after having to in the past visit so
many
um I forgot what I was going to say but
I think my comments really were going
back to East berl's neighborhood plan um
mentioning again laam laam are on the
the final stage of their review which
was made in the same year as yours which
is 20
2016 um so I would urge you to have a
look at that within your neighborhood
plan I believe
that you um that your restriction is on
the number of properties that you wish
to see within the village at any one
time and this obviously this number of
four is well under under the figure that
I remember being quoted um my other
comments actually do come back again to
to the um to the to the car park yes it
is protected under under your your
neighborhood plan I reiterate again you
are so lucky that you have a private
person a private landlord that has a
piece of land that is that are that is
allowing a car
park I see some shaking of heads but
we're all entitled to our own comments
we do not have that in other places you
should be well aware of that but really
what I'm trying to say is although you
may think that your neighborhood plan is
being um pushed into the long grass I
think the interpretation of it is being
looked at very thoroughly very carefully
and very
compassionately um and I still stand by
what I say that I would I would support
the officer's
recommendation thank you thank you
councelor maybe councelor hold you were
looking yeah it was just the obviously
the neighborhood plans there's a plan
member I mean we personally look at
neighborhood plans and and give them a
lot of weight as they truly deserve but
they contain policies which are no
different to our local plan policies and
National policies they're there for
interpretation and they do run their
time and sometimes they run out of date
and they need refreshing so I'd just
like to reassure Parish Council and
members of the public that personally I
always look at an neb plan and give it
as much weight as it deserves and in
this case it deserves a lot of weight
but the interpretation of policies that
it contains as is presented by the
officer is that it supports this type of
development um and I can't see within
the current neighborhood plan any reason
to go against the officer's
recommendation on a balance of all the
policies that are in there and in our
new local plan and in the
mppf um but I just want to reassure that
the neighborhood plan is given it full
weight thank
you any more comments if
not Cal
register um so I've listened to that
debate and I'm as conflicted as several
other members um B&B and the storage no
problem whatsoever don't think anybody's
got any problem with
that uh the dwellings do they meet
neighborhood plan policies do they meet
the policies the jop or us our own
special policies seems to be a matter of
debate
I'm what do we what do we what message
are we sending if we ignore the
neighborhood plan but it's we we then
end up in interpretation of the
neighborhood plan as the planning
officers uh planning Chief planning
officer pointed out and then we come to
the car park
um and the toilets I I really am not
convinced that two toilets to serve a
um serve one coach party is enough I'm
sorry um having worked in mford for a
number of years and watched coaches
arrive and watch the cues for the
toilets in local
pubs I am unconvinced
I'm on the basis of the car park and
my lack of conviction in the
interpretation of the policies I'm
minded to
refuse thank
you thank
you anyone
else if not I'll get the chief planning
officer to sum up what the
uh proposal is at this
time chairman I wasn't actually going to
do that if I if I may I might just take
a small detour via eb11 of the
neighborhood plan if we could get that
up on the screen just so we have the
words in front of us and understand the
uh issue okay bearing in mind you will
have to then look at the
proposal thank
you so
so
so eb1 says the redline car and Coach
Park identified on map sh 19 should be
safeguarded for parking doesn't say for
how many cars or coaches it just says
for
parking change of use of the site shall
only be permitted if alternative parking
provision of a similar size is provided
in a location accessible to the Loc
facilities in the village heart now
whether this policy says what people
wanted it to say when they thought they
were getting to that point I don't know
but applying that policy um and I will
ask my case officer just to confirm this
is not a change of use of the site as
far as I can see no change of use and in
terms of parking there is nothing
specified numerically in eb1 which we
believe would be offended now
appreciating the aspiration here you
have three options as far as I can see
there's a Rec there's there's a motion
to
approve if you don't wish to go down
that route then uh I will be looking for
a reason for refusal from committee and
I will need members to give me the harm
and the policy references that justify
that reason so that that can be defended
should the matter go to
appeal um
if there are issues that you feel have
not been addressed within this
application then the other alternative
is to seek to defer it and to seek
Amendment or revision to those issues um
you've got a motion on the table that's
as far as I'm going to go at the moment
chair thank
you no comments right we'll go to a vote
um do you
want CL have you got exactly what the uh
motion says yes as the as is per
officer's recommendation the Voting is
now
open councelor beer can I take your vote
approve thank
you
counselor Hulk can I just ask you to
yeah thank
you
councelor granson are you having
problems would you okay thank
you thank you members chair that's six
votes for and four against therefore
that's carried that's carried thank you
very and let me say five minute break
while we clear the room and get ready
for the next one please will you stick
to 5 minutes and if you're going
out
Right Moving
On planning application DC
22475 Brett veil's Golf Club noes Road
Raiden IP 75 LR um I will now ask the
case officer Emily
vik to
introduce the application to us if you
would
be thank you chair and good afternoon
members um this application is DC stroke
22047 51 at the site addressed as
bretteville Golf Club noes Road within
the radi Parish it a full planning
application seeking change of use of
land for the sighting of 38 lodges in
addition to an existing number of nine
sorry Em em pleas you
get
apologies pull it toward
[Music]
you am I coming through better yep great
um and the construction of raised
decking for each
unit
this presentation is provided as a
further Visual and spoken accompaniment
to the committee report and is not
designed to supplant the information
contained in that report is intended to
Pro provide members with an introduction
to the application and a springboard for
discussion of the information in the
report of points raised by speakers and
in other
representations since publication of the
committee report Please be aware that
place Services landscape has provided
recommon which has been tabled they have
acknowledged that the amended 38 Lodge
layout and noted the concern for the
formalized Avenue of tree planting along
the track serving the additional 38
lodges this is considered to be
unsympathetic to the rural
landscape for this application to date
there has been 40 representations
received in response to public
consultation
and a further additional representation
made this morning that brings the T to
36 in objection four were in support and
one was of a neutral stance the most
common matters raised in consultation
were the increased traffic highways
impact impact to local Wildlife impact
to
landscape um light pollution and noise
and the scale of the development Vel
M the red line plan was amended on the
6th of November 2023 to the reduce site
area of
7.35 hectares it should be noted that
the red line now includes the existing
car park with a capacity of 150 spaces
the
clubhouse and the exist isting access to
the noes Road Highway here serving the
golf
club and this spoke off of the car park
here serves an existing nine lodges that
are not quite fully represented on this
plan the blue line that is cut off is
the remainder of the ating Hole Golf
Club um and it's approximately 46
hectares the highway here Su Hill
separates the red line site in two
portions this is a unclassified road
that is designated as a quiet Lane and
has a national speed
limit these photographs show the
crossing point on the sulles hill road
so you can see the site is Split in Two
and the top photo shows the view looking
towards the site where the nine lodges
are that were observed at the committee
site visit and on the bottom photo you
can see the isolated portion of the site
it should be noted that the area seeking
change of of use in the red line is
towards the left of the frame and the
area remaining as recreational Golf
Course land is um to the right of the
frame so there's still a portion that
remains blue uh blue lined on that
isolated path of
land currently this land is in
recreational use and is laid out as the
13th 14th and 15th and 16th and 17th
holes of the golf club so that is
Loosely speaking number
17 is here number 133 would be here
number
16 is about
here number 15 runs this way and number
14 runs this direction on that land so
it's mainly with the reduced Red Line
the holes 14 and 15 that are now
affected by the change of use for the
sighting of 38
lodges you can see that the
topographical survey has picked up some
bunkers um and the wooded areas are
mainly the rough areas um of the current
Golf Course
arrangement in the northeastern corner
you can just see the Turning Circle for
those nine lodges these were approved
under DC stroke
433 they were given permission with a
condition attached restricting their
occupation to um short-term
holidays uh so that they cannot be used
as a sole residence The Operators and
owners of the nine lodges are required
to keep a log of the uh visitors to the
site with their addresses
es for this application there has been
an indicative proposed Golf Course
Redevelopment plan
supplied this is shown here on the
screen and shows the relocation of the
holes on that isolated piece of land
onto the main golf course so 17 and 18
have now adjusted
accordingly by this indicative
plan it should be noted however that the
proposal's
description
um does not explicitly include the
potential for the associated um
engineering works for the Redevelopment
of the golf
course but the planning statement does
suggest and acknowledge that to um
deliver the 38 lodges on site at least
three of the golf course holes would
need to be
relocated this Aral map shows the site
in the context of The Wider 18 hole golf
course so that's outlined in light blue
here to give you an idea of how that
stretches out and is mainly um where the
the main Golf Course facilities are
located so the clubhouse and the
existing car
park the um area also shows the
relationship of the site to the nearest
settlement Raiden so in planning terms
this site is within the
countryside um which is deemed under
policy spo3 to be the least sustainable
location to host new
development it should also be noted that
ra en is um a hinterland Village and not
very well served by public services um
facilities and transport
connection there is a bus stop at
rectory close but that has not been
confirmed whether that's still in use um
presently the site is subject to some
other constraints also in particular um
from surface water flooding so this map
from the environmental agency's
long-term flood risk um mapping tool
shows the land
here is subject to a small proportion
just there of surface water flooding
still um and also in the context of The
Wider gulf course reaching up to
here as we saw before on the aerial plan
it is peppered with small areas of
surface water
pooling there is one area more towards
Mount Pleasant here that is of a similar
proportion to the site area under
consideration of this application and
does appear to have less instances of
surface water
flooding
therefore in considering this
application the mppf sequential test
under
paragraph 167 I believe is engaged for
this
application some other site constraints
to be aware of are the cluster of listed
buildings these are grade two towards
the Northwest here
the um public footpath network running
from the boundary to the South with the
site leading up to the
settlement and the other residential
neighbors so there's Pippins here just
on the corner and snow Downs which does
share boundaries with the site it is
understood that these paddocks here are
a registered private Nature Reserve with
suffet County
Council and there is also the constraint
for the site being borderline with the
era of outstanding natural beauty so the
dead and
Veil this is the proposed site layout
Pres presented for the change of use and
the arrangement of the 38
lodges you can see that the gross
density when considering usable area
under the calculation for Caravan
licensing comes at 10 lodges per
Hector it is understood that the Caravan
licensing
calculation um suggests that a maximum
density of 60 lodges per Hector would be
considered appropriate in terms of
Licensing a caravan
site generally speaking The Lodges are
spaced at least 10 meters apart and
you'll note they are spread across from
the existing turning Circle still using
the crossing point and then spread
around a Ring Road here
that ring Road Track is a width of 4 M
across and is an extension to that
existing uh spoke from the main car
park as members will have observed at
the site visit there are nine existing
holiday lodges on site this photo shows
one of them the intention is to to um
have the new lodges in a similar color
palette so muted tones that would be
sympathetic to the
landscape and as the planning statement
suggests these Caravans would meet these
lodges would meet the legal definition
to be classed as a caravan but would not
have a resemblance to a caravan in the
traditional
sense
members should be aware that Caravans
are not considered development um but
you do need to change the use of the
land for their sighting which is what
this application is considering within
that red
line there have been three example Lodge
models put forward forward um that could
be cited upon the land these are shown
here the
top um elevations show The Havana Lodge
model this is a two-bedroom unit the
middle elevations shown here show the
cad deluso model which is a free bedroom
unit and the
bottom elevations here show the Bell
Vista model which is a two-bedroom unit
again these are are labeled that they
meet the um British standard BS
3632 for residential Park
Homes um which would essentially be the
legal definition of a
caravan there is no um mix suggested on
the previous site layout that we looked
at for these free models if they were to
be used
um in terms of arrangement
however the general Arrangement would be
um a freestanding rais deck as shown
here by this blue
L-shaped um block and then the lodge
cited adjacent to it and that rais
Terrace would give access into the
individual lodges so there are a number
of steps here and
here
the design of The Lodges was commented
upon by the a officers they had some
concerns for the amount of glazing that
was shown on those modules that were
given as
examples um they also have concerns in
terms of the impact of external
lighting and the impact of noise upon
the Tran quility and Scenic Beauty and
the dark sky status of the
aom this uh proposal is supported by a
landscape impact assessment and a
external lighting um
scheme this plan here is from the uh
impact assessment for the landscape and
shows the site's relationship with a
wider
a the land immediately adjacent to the
site is considered to be Upland Fringe
character area and these are the
examples of the bards um with a downward
cow and the down lights with a Time
operation that have been put forward um
to serve the
development it is also indicated by the
planning statement that The Lodges would
be um
there would sorry there would be some
wildf flower Meadows incorporated into
the arrangement of The Lodges for
landscape
enhancement but it should be noted that
the proposal relies heavily on the
existing um screening of the landscape
that is at the boundary of the site this
is shown here by an image within the
planning
statement these are well established um
tree belts and hedge
rows lp8 calls
for um non- major development and
development in the setting of The am to
integrate positively with the um special
landscape reinforced distinctive
character enhance the scenic Beauty um
and be sensitive to the natural
landscapes um defining features such as
the dark skies and its
Tranquility for context this is how the
site appears from the a andb the top
photo was taken looking at the public
footpath route that runs adjacent to the
site boundary to the South this is the
established tree planting that is at the
border there and helps to screen the
development
site from the um inside of the of the
site which is the land again to the
sorry to the left on this occasion so
this is a photo taken looking for a gap
within that um tree planting here so
there is small glimpses that can be seen
but what is notable is the contrast in
the landscape so the um recreational
land is obviously um has a appearance of
being managed um manicured whilst the
surrounding land of theb is um much more
agricultural um and in in contrast to
the kept manner of the golf
course these photos show the screening
from the Sully Hills access again so
there is a well established hedge row
along the side boundary there and also
um for awareness the amount of uh
screening afforded by the established
planting does differ in the winter
months so this photo was taken in the
winter of 22 when there was snow on the
ground um and you can see that the trees
um have lost their leaves at this time
so there is um potential for for more
light spillage to occur towards the A&B
in these circumstances and the site is
much less
contained a detail has been given for
the track to be extended to serve the uh
lodges this is the construction detail
here um you can see that it is um
treated with a limestone aggregate
surface so chipped
finish the planning statement suggests
that the arrangement would be for the um
visitors to use golf carts from a pool
of shared golf carts um golf sorry golf
carts to transport the visitors from the
uh reception at the Glo um at the golf
course to each Lodge where there would
be an electric vehicle charger available
um to recharge the golf
buggies and um private car parking of
the visitors would be Reliant upon the
spare capacity of the
150 space car park um so that is
intended to meet the demand of The
Lodges and uh continue to serve the
membership of the golf course uh we have
no details of the current membership um
so cannot confirm under policy LP 29 if
there's capacity to serve both the
additional need of the 38 lodges and the
um membership of the golf club's
day-to-day
needs uh these photos show the existing
Arrangement um for parking and access to
the nine lodges that were observed at
the committee site visit you can see
that the track um that is already laid
is treated differently to that which is
proposed for the additional it is
tarmaced and there is the ability for
private car parking to occur at The
Lodges on the nine that are existing so
there would be a different Arrangement
um for the additional 38 as to what
there is at the moment but that's um
shown here in these photos you can also
see the existing Clubhouse house um and
the residence of the managers which the
planning statement um suggests would
manage the um movement so the
um access to to The
Lodges these photos um are just a a
visual on the condition of the car park
this was taken on a snow day where the
course was closed in
2022 um so there was obviously no
vehicles parked there at the time and
this is the existing access point to
noes road so so serving the golf club
you can see the visibility here and that
there is no laid pavement the settlement
can be reached in this direction
here it's
appro
the
highways um Team have removed their
holding objections since the submission
of a traffic highways mitigation scheme
it is proposed to create free new
vehicle passing places along the
surrounding quiet Lanes so that would be
noes Road Raiden Road and sand pitz Lane
so that sorry it's a little bit
difficult to see but that would be one
here on S Pit's Lane which is the same
one
repeated
here one here on Raiden road so this is
your main access just up here with the
car
park oh sorry no noes
Road here and this is the one on raen
road so that's free free and
total this
photo again shows the approach from the
East to the S Hills crossing point just
seen here um it is signposted on this
tree um but what this photo shows is
that there is a degree of um surface
water pooling after recent rainfall on
the approach
here the scheme has been supported by a
flood risk assessment um this image here
is taken from the most recent version
supplied for the 38
lodges it shows um in detail where the
areas at most flood risk are so there
are mainly pools towards the um north of
the
site which unfortunately this red line
has not reflected the change that has
recently occurred but I believe that is
still within the red line and this
certainly is here and here but what is
also notable is there are small areas
there is a light blue here where that
photo was taken and there was um the
pooling that had occurred and there was
obviously um surface water pulling um at
high risk here on the sulles hill in
both sides of that crossing point to be
aware
of the proposal is also Al supported by
a drainage strategy um in response to
the surface water flood
risk it is proposed to um channel the
surface water along the um Ring Road
that would be extended from the existing
um track serving those nine
lodges in this instance the water would
drain either to a soak away or to an
attenuation Pond here um and is also
shown that there would be a packaged um
private sewage treatment plant to serve
these lodges as well the suffk um floods
and water team have um maintained a
holding objection for the latest flood
risk assessment that has been submitted
and the drainage strategy for surface
water um saying that it's insufficient
detail for um this scale of
application so overule the um proposal
is considered contrary to the
development plan on account of this
site's location in the countryside for
which spo3 is resistive of new
development apart from in exceptional
circumstances um as allowed in
accordance with another policy from The
Joint local plan
such as
lp12
um Criterion two here for which
extensions to existing tourism
facilities outside of settlement
boundaries may be supported where the
proposal is of an appropriate scale for
their
context amongst other um expectations
that have been listed
above for this application there is the
concern from the a B Team um project
team raised for the scale in particular
um not being respectful that has an
estate likee quality to it um and would
potentially impact the Tranquility of
the a so that also is in conflict with
um another policy specifically LP 18 of
the joint local plan um that safeguards
um the special qualities of
theb
under
spo3 um there is also allowance by
lp13 um if the proposal Accords with it
for um new tourist accommodation within
the
countryside
um if it can be demonstrated that there
is an overriding business need for it to
be in that location
and also if it's an extension such as
this to upgrade an exis um
existing um provision then it must
deliver a balanced mix of economic
social and environmental
benefits um limited and high level
justification has been given in the
planning statement for a business need
um such as the
increase of employment at the site so
raising from 15 to 20 full-time
positions which are detailed as um
working in reception um management of
the new uh lodges the clubhouse the
function room um general cleaning and
housekeeping
roles but it should be noted that this
was um prepared this planning statement
for the larger scheme as well so it has
hasn't been updated to reflect the 38
Lodge
scheme the um intention is to
um to increase the business offerings
that obviously are already in place
um and the need that is given is that
there is a decline Nationwide experience
with um golf membership and following
the covid um pandemic there is a um
interest in
stations um that has increased and they
would like to continue to diversify the
business um with this
offering there is also the aspiration
alluded to to redevelop the golf
course the applicant has submitted a
brief business plan uh which indicated
the proposed allocation of Finance um
from the sale of some of the lodges to
then um acquire the other set of lodges
so it would be a staged arrangement of
financing the economic development team
have um had a look at the details of the
business plan that was
provided and were um have advised that
it appeared to be reasonable in terms of
the financing
Arrangement however it should be noted
that there is no mechanism um to secure
that the finances from The Lodges would
then be fed back into the course
Redevelopment in consideration of um
paragraph 187 of the mppf um for
effective use of land um the new
development should be integrated with
the existing business and not uh cause
unreasonable restrictions upon it there
is still concern surrounding um the
uncertainty of the speculative Golf
Course uh
rearrangement and the scale of the
development's impact upon the Core
Business
um which could give a rise to conflict
between uh the two uses as one is in
intensified
um and also if the Redevelopment of the
GOL course is not followed through in
the phase manner as suggested by the
planning
statement um therefore under
spo7 new sustainable tourism development
will be supported in the district when
it's of appropriate scale character and
and nature for the locality the scale of
this development remains questionable
for its um whether it's appropriate to
the A and also um whether it would cause
a
um conflict with the Core Business
activity on the
site I'm missing a
slide no
[Music]
problem U touched on several times about
the relocation of the three holes that
would be um built on effectively um but
there was no evidence as to to where
that relocation would be I think in
slide six you showed us uh a map when
talking about re relocating the three
holes but there was no evidence of to
where they would be is that
correct that map does show the
relocation of the fre holes the missing
element is um the existing Arrangement
is not properly detailed can we get
slide six up and just show me where the
three holes would be
please
yeah if you would
mind okay
[Music]
so bear with me I've just got to get my
bearings on where the existing holes 14
16 okay um right so at the moment with
the red line reduced it would seem that
it would be 15 and 14 that are most
affected so 15 is here presently and 14
is here that's my understanding of the
current arrangement of the golf course
but I've not had a plan to confirm that
the I think yeah the issue is is that
the rearrangement doesn't give us the
full picture of the total land ownership
and the golf course Arrangement so we
cannot see where um those golf numbers
would be relocated to it may be that
they're further up the golf course and
it's had a KnockOn effect and other
holes have been designated or re
relabeled but I can't confirm that for
you nothing's been supplied by the
applicant to show where the three
because number 16 I think went on the
site visit was confirmed is not going to
be used so it was three holes that were
going to be um put aside for this and no
provision has been supplied by the
applicant as to where they would be
relocated to Ure that the 18 hole golf
course continues as 18 holes is that
correct yes that's correct thank you
second question if I may carry on um the
ownership of three paron places you
mentioned um again I assume the
applicant does not own the land to be
able to confirm that these three parsing
places would actually be permitted yep
that's that's correct it would have to
be through a
um agreement with s um sou County
council's highways team and a third
question you mentioned sale of the
current
lodges to fund the rebuilding of the
golf course um so it would not be sale
of the current lodges um perhaps I
didn't explain it very well the business
plan that was received suggested that
the 38 would be uh split into two two
portions and some of those would be sold
on to then sell uh and fund the um other
half of the 38 so if we were to give
permission for this we would be actually
permitting lodges to be built and sold
as permanent residents rather than
holiday lodges so we don't have a um
management agreement or we we only have
a business plan that is limited in
detail for how they would be managed but
essentially um yeah there is the danger
that they could be sold off thank
you councelor
gron thank you um my first question is
is it no road the road that leads to the
car park and to the site um how many
um premises does that road serve please
other other residences and so
on
uh along the main road um is it called
noes
road to the car park yeah could I get a
map up to
help think which is
the
okay so yeah this stretch here is noes
Road and that is obviously serving at
the moment the golf course which has the
nine existing lodges there is also the
residence of the um manager of the and
owner of the golf course um as part of
that so that's 10 residences there um I
believe this land here here is an
equestrian center there is the listed
building here just shown so I think that
would also be within noes road so that's
up to 11 and I think there's a couple of
properties cut off
here that I I can't confirm to you how
many there are but possibly two more um
so about 13 probably no more than 15
properties thank you and um my other
question is I might have misunder
something when we went on the site
visit I had thought that it was a foot
path a public foot path that was
crossing the site and that you showed us
but have I misunderstood is it because I
think um you mentioned about the um
vehicles meet um and it being the normal
vehicle speed I can't remember the
correct terminology for that um so is it
an actual road that goes through the
site please please could you yeah enable
me to understand what I saw I just get
the photo back up for
you trying to think which one would be
the best one
to
show what's going on on the
ground um so the indicative
layout as it is
um do you mean do you mean the extension
to the road whether that's a public foot
path no the um it was I thought I had
understood it as a public foot paath
going through the site near where the um
um new um loges are going to be put but
I'm now thinking it's not a public foot
path it's a vehicular route or have I
misunderstood could you explain uh it
might be sull Hill I'm not
sure okay so su's Hill is a Highway um
it's acquire it's designated as a quiet
road so under that designation there is
um less traffic movement so it is more
suitable for walking so it is used by um
horse riders and and members of the
public frequently walk along that so
it's not a public footpath as such but
there's um because of its designation as
a quiet Road it is frequented by
Walkers is is that so car so maybe
that's the one um so but cars can use it
then can is it it's a highway with a
national speed limit I had misunderstood
thank you very much that's
helpful thank you councelor Hulk do you
had another question yeah I was just
picking up on councel gron really I
think you showed in one slide um the
makeup of a track um which I believe was
running from the main Car Park area
which was going to lead to All The
Lodges down at the lower end now that
track was purely of a shingle sto stroke
Stone makeup which is purely like for
buggies no Vehicles would be able to use
it it wouldn't be wide enough or
constructed to hold a vehicle is that
correct it's I'm I can't confirm if it
is constructed to hold the weight of a
vehicle it was commented on by one of
the consules that it would need to be
able to accommodate a refu collection I
believe
um I can't remember which Consulting it
must be in the the wayte
services
um it's it's 4 M it's it would be
finished by shingle it's it's supposed
to be permeable to capture the the
surface water and it is presented as
only being uh for use at for
transportation of The Visitors by the
golf carts from the shed pool there
hasn't been any suggestion that it would
be used by the private um for for the
private uh vehicles of the of the
visitors just that when we were on the
site visit um I believe the applicant
confirmed that there would be only buggy
access to The Lodgers um and no vehicles
would be permitted to park beside them
which rais various concerns about
emergency vehicles and access for
ambulances Etc of people faal and also
um it's I think it's crucial that we are
fully aware of what track that is and
what vehicles it can take because to me
there's a large concern about emergency
access Vehicles being permitted on the
site and been able to get to The Lodges
if they were given permission okay um
the S um the fire Services St fire
Services have commented and they haven't
raised objection to the scheme I believe
in that
regard again looking at the fire
Services letter it's it's some of us
could advise us here it's basically
passing the buck to angle in water um
don't really comment one way or the
other to be honest it's it references
volume part one b
five volume two part B I mean the these
mean nothing to us they may mean
something to you but would a fire engine
be able to get on that site without
being bogged down and G gain access 600
meters from the nearest water supply you
know what it's a concern that's what I'm
saying you mean you're in the situation
where you think it may not have been
fully thought out I concur yes CH thank
you councelor Wyman you
next thank you chair uh this question
may give help me have a bit of context
around what we're sort of seeking to
look at today but on Slide Five it shows
the um the ongoing requirement of
development and the time restriction on
holiday LS I think that was in relation
to the original planning application DC
433 um could I ask if the applicant is
compliant with that current requirement
would anyone
know I can check for you whether there's
an enforcement case there I don't
believe there
is thank you my second and slightly sort
of further Point really relates to a
point Council Hal made in relation to
the sale of uh sale of assets
there's an expectation that from the
initial uh requirement in the point n
that they have some control over the way
these operate so in relation to the sale
of the holiday rental um might this not
give lack of control to the applicants
by the sale of the uh the homes to to
other people and the further question
really is you know what is the
definition of holiday um
the office older made reference to
short-term holidays um you know are we
talking about short-term holidays I mean
when we undertook the site visit the
nine original homes look quite permanent
in all honesty um it's difficult to
differentiate when someone's got quite a
elaborate garden shed and various other
Assets in their Gardens that they
possibly be Holiday
Homes and you couldn't possibly comment
on the substantial wheels that were
hidden up inside the homes I can I just
ask your question do I understand what
we're talking about with a holiday L
like this is that it is limited to 11
months of the
year there have been various ways of
looking at this problem the 11 month a
year um solution didn't work because it
typically would be a month in February
and they just going to live in Spain you
know so it didn't work what we tend to
do now is um something like no more than
28 days um within a certain period of
time I think perhaps that condition that
that Emily showed there I don't know if
that's the right one but it's it's all
about limiting the number of times and
the amount of time somebody's there at
any given time and also it shouldn't be
their main home
okay seems to deviate chair from the
principle of a holiday isn't it really
sorry can you repeat it seems to deviate
from the principle of what we might all
consider to be a sensible holiday when
you can almost have 11 months of the
year occupancy
yeah councelor maor you are next um yes
thank you chairman um my learnard
colleagues have asked all the quiet
questions I was going to ask by one
which is under
7.19 um you mentioned something about an
increase in
functions um so does this mean that the
whole business principle is being geared
up several
notches it's under
7.19 I don't know on what slide but that
was the
number it was more towards the end I
think sorry I didn't write the slide
number now I just write the
number I can find it on another
page so it was a question about the
business plan yes the business plan
because it it mentions about upgrading
to
um
upgrading this is included within their
planning statement also yeah that's the
one it will also continue to expand the
market for functions including weddings
conferences
so basically the business plan um from
me reading that is that they are going
to upgrade um and substantially expand
um the the business which will obviously
be more and more people to that
area yeah the the business plan does
elude that The Lodges um the finance
would would feed back into the golf
course and Redevelopment of it and the
facilities that they offer um but um as
men mentioned that there isn't a
mechanism to secure that the um the
profits from from The Lodges and the
benefits of that would would feed back
in I'm sorry that that's not my question
my question is that business plan is
trying to um expand further and further
what they're offering so that will
increase the um the visitor numbers
however you'd like to call it to that
area substantially because we we're
talking weddings weddings can be 30 or I
mean I've been to weddings that are 600
people so what are we looking at or
don't we know um yeah so they do propose
that they want to diversify their
offerings as a business um this is the
information I have for that I have no
more than this okay thank you I think
you've got to take that we we're we're
looking at this application as it stands
and and and in the report there has been
problems I think making contact with the
applicant to discuss the business plan
Phil would you like f in on that thank
you uh chairman I think I mean we've had
the application for some while um Emily
has referred to various things which um
aren't part of the application as it
sits before you today and as you rightly
say chairman decide the application in
front of you not one you might like to
have um so I think it's fair to say
there's you know you've got the
information you've got and you must make
a decision on what's in front of you
just so you're aware on this business
Point um the applicant did email me
yesterday in the afternoon and that's
not in your late papers but just to
summarize um he's told me he's uh he's
now for various personal reasons
relinquished responsibility to his son
and his son's had to let go of five
members of Staff because this is a long
running and very expensive application
um uh Mark and I have met with him I
think he um he feels that that meeting
was um uh un unhelped from from his
point of view in uh in business terms um
and he uh is uh concerned this is his
third unsuccessful planning application
uh which has taken uh 15 months and it's
had its toll on both him and the
business um he made some comments about
the uh hostility which he feels he's
experienced um locally and I'm not going
to repeat those comments here um but I
think his perspective is that he's
invested over2 200,000 trying to get
this application to a form that works um
uh and he uh you know would like his
business to grow and prosper um and
chairman I don't think there's much more
I can add other than to say that's his
perspective on where we
are thank you councilor beer you have a
question for your well Mr chairman I'm
fortunate I've got to leave because I
have another commitment this afternoon
uh but what I wanted to say and I think
the questions to you you the fact my
colleagues behind us um brought up three
good points and then I think you had a f
one one of you as well um which the
officer couldn't with great respect um
give the answers because she wasn't made
aware of them and she could only surmise
on some of them and give how she
interpreted it if I'm correct and now
what the chief plan and officers said
that he's find that great difficulty
with speaking to the applicants or
getting them to talk more more I was
wondering whether we should defer this
to get more information but it doesn't
sound like you would get more
information after here and that but um
uh as I say I have to leave but um if
you can just answer that point before I
go I don't know whether there's anything
other than sitting here and debating it
for a long
time my advice would be as described by
the case officer it's been a long it's
gone on for a long time it did follow a
negative pre-application
um case probably two years ago now and
the message has generally been the same
we haven't been presented with a
credible business case um so that's
where we are all this time later so I
wouldn't recommend
deferring sorry I have to go and I'm
sorry Mr chairman I've had to rely on a
lift today so I need to go too very
sorry
but
with a much reduced number should we
carry on chair I could just answer that
question um Council woman about
enforcement case effectively um we did
have an allegation of a breach of the
condition um earlier this year and the
case is closed so I'd have to say my
record show there's no live case which
is alleging a breach of of the condition
of
occupancy any other
questions fine we have public speakers
the first one
is case officers just said to me that
the there was there should have been a
slide with some reasons for refus on as
you normally expect and it's not do you
want to just
tell it's in the written report it's in
the papers anyway so as long as members
are happy with that we don't leave them
read out again you talk about the
reasons for refusing no it was just to
give the
recommendation um it matches with um
with those in the report and there was
was a tabled reason which is a lack of
um biodiversity net gain so that's all I
wanted to make aware
of shair I add to that I yes as as he
left did suggest that we put any other
reasons as the chief planning officer
may see fit
okay okay thank
you we have now a
not
Scot okay Andrew Scot from Shelly Parish
meeting hasn't joined us um in that case
we'll move to Jane
tan who uh is a member
of um Raiden Parish Council yes thank
you you have five uh sorry three minutes
I can find the right Implement to
address the committee thank you I would
just like to say that uh we have serious
objections to this
application uh there are nine lodges
already on the golf
course um in a previous meeting we were
informed by somebody who lives in one of
those lodges that they have a 12- month
dwelling and they live there permanently
for your
information um the um application for
for 38 further lodges are sold with 12
month dwellings as long as the resident
has a second
address um The Lodges are in View and
adjacent to an A O with a foot paath on
the boundary which we feel would be
spoiling the enjoyment of Walkers um and
um people in the
area um there's a lot of dog walkers and
and lot of um Countryside Pursuits
people walking and and enjoying that
area uh there are badges on the site of
this land uh we have concerns about the
impact um it has on them and of the
wildlife in general with that um uh
amount of
habitation um the access to these lodges
is not uh viable as it's intended that
residents should use buggies parks some
distance away in the main Gulf car park
to transport shopping and their daily
for their daily needs the buggies would
cross over the narrow Quiet Lane um it's
designated Quiet Lane um and um would be
a hazard to motorists using uh the lane
um and I think we need special
consideration to the number of people
residing uh in these lodges um The
Lodges uh house up to six persons uh in
three double bedrooms uh for some of
them um uh and also uh it was mentioned
that um there is a bus stop in Raiden uh
but there is no bus
service um the change of use for the
land um where The Lodges are to be cited
um we're losing three golfing Hall holes
and we're concerned that um
there uh no real places to put those
extra holes um but it was still stated
that there's going to be an 18-hole Golf
Course other Parcels of land are for
sale on the golf course which begs the
question um is this going to become
eventually a Holiday Village uh we're
concerned about the increase of traffic
on the narrow country lanes um also
access of emergency vehicles
um which might be necessary for the
residents um on the lane uh in question
we have uh substantial flooding in two
areas um and we're concerned that the
increase of waste waterer Etc from the
lodes could impact on this situation I
think let me stop you there you've had a
good three minutes thank
you have we any questions for the
speaker
no then thank you very
much an objector Lorraine
May
sorry sorry I'm not objecting I'm yeah
I'm I'm objecting the application um if
I could just explain somebody was asking
about noes Road and the houses and
everything is is that permittable for me
um above the drawing there are actually
quite a few properties and it's not just
those properties the street that leads
to no road is quite a heavily um
populated Road um thank you so the
traffic that would come down there is
yeah anyway you have three minutes to
address the committee if you like um so
yes so that that would be I'm obviously
here representing um the residents
and I have grave concerns about the
quiet Lanes as well um they are very
very narrow country lanes um even if
you're down there walking it's
it's quite dangerous at times
um the traffic that would come down the
street into Raiden would just be
horrendous um trying for to get down to
noes Road as I've said there's an
equestrian center there there are plenty
of residents there living you know who
like to use these Lanes as recreational
which is why they're now designated
designated quiet Lanes um our fear is
that these lodges will be sold on two
are actually for sale at the moment and
in the fael it does State they are
12-month
occupancy
um which beggar you know are they
actually going to be holiday
LS um I can only really just reiterate
what our Parish counselor has said and
um really oppose this
application thank you very much thank
you are you willing to answer questions
if we have questions any got any
questions no thank you very much
indeed thank you
chairman this is a complicated
application to decide on one side is the
legitimate Des desire of a business to
diversify and expand and we do want to
encourage expansion of our visitor
economy but on the other side our
planning policies which are there to
protect the countryside from
inappropriate development must be
respected the owners of the business are
committed to developing a golf course
that is sensitive to the environment and
it is a very pleasant facility staff are
loyal hardworking and are clearly
invested in the business's future I do
understand that the golf club sector is
not as strong as it used to be and that
diversification is an inevitable
consequence of this but this development
is a fundament fundamentally different
use that will adversely impact on the
environment it is a significant
development and there's a huge amount of
local opposition because of the impact
on the surrounding Countryside the
opposition is not just from residents
Raiden and hton Parish councils have
responded as as the planning officer for
the dead and Vil National landscape many
residents have contacted me and all have
real worries about the impact of this
proposal these worries have been
exacerbated by concerns about the future
now that this site and two other sites
on the the golf course are up for sale
as with all applications this must be
assessed against planning policies the
mppf and our own local policies the
application has taken a long time to get
to committee and during this time our
joint local plan has been adopted the
design and access statement refers to uh
therefore uh obsolete policies which
have now been superseded by our new ones
however irrespective of whether CS3 or
SBO 7 as the relevant tourism policy
they both qualify support for Rural
businesses with a statement where
appropriate to the scale character
nature of their locality these
qualifying factors are addressed by
other policies in the local plan policy
spo3 addressing the sustainable location
of new development is very clear that
development outside of a settlement
boundary will not be permitted unless it
is in accordance with spo7 and lp12 the
tourism policies the scale impact on the
countryside and lack of accessibility
are contrary to these policies and this
is reinforced by lp13 which addresses
tourism acon accommodation in the
countryside particularly par paragraphs
1 and three it is a sensitive location
and although not within the dead and
Bale National landscape the golf course
have buts it on two sides including the
location of the proposed lodges on the
southwestern side of the course regard
must therefore be played to uh be paid
to policy lp18 which is which addresses
the safeguarding of the dead and Veil
because it is so close and due to its
scale the development will be a
significant visible presence and it will
have an unavoidable impact on dark skies
and Tranquility within the national land
landscape siis Hill is a single track
Quiet Lane that cannot support much
traffic because of its remoteness and
quiet Lane status it is much used by
Walkers and horse riders as is the as is
the adjacent public right of way leading
into the national
landscape County highways H has removed
its holding objection now that the
applicant has agreed to additional
passing places however this acknowledges
that there will be extra traffic and not
just this Lane there will also be extra
traffic from the a12 going along sanit
sanitz Lane hton Mary hence the
additional passing place there the extra
traffic is not in keeping with the very
rural location adjacent to the National
landscape although the design and access
statement says that the loges will only
be accessed bya golf buggy monitored by
CCTV with vehicles entering along the
existing drive to the golf course car
park from notes road which is also a
quiet Lane this is unrealistic and
access points on sulles Hill will likely
be used by cars and larger Vehicles
moreover despite what has been said and
provided by Consul te
there is no consideration for adequate
access by emergency vehicles these will
require a considerable extension to the
existing entrance and they will use it
anyone requiring emergency assistance
will undoubtedly give the what three
words location to direct the respondents
to The
Lodgers um in the absence of Shel Parish
meeting the the last word on on traffic
I know will come from them they are
concerned that an increase in traffic
from the gulf course to Hadley will use
the shell route which is also a single
track Lane and already becoming much
busier because of congestion on Benton
Street and Hadley I do sympathize with
the applicant plight regarding the
viability of the golf club but whilst
promoting the rural economy is supported
by our planning policies this is simply
the wrong place for a large number of
Lodgers we cannot allow development in
the open Countryside along a quiet Lane
adjacent to a national landscape thank
you
chairman thank you Council
award any questions for Council
award
no thank
you the item for
debate Council H kick up thank you chair
um having read the papers listen to the
officer and and the speakers I I can
only um say and reiterate that we are
open for businesses the district council
which does include
tourism however this is not my opinion a
well thought out or complete plan
application and I agree with the plan
and officer proposed that we uh
recommend uh go along with the officer's
recommendation and that is one of
refusal um I personally don't see
prolong in this I don't see debate is
going to um eradicate in my opinion the
issues that I see with it but I'd like
to obviously get other members opinions
but yeah I would uh like to propose we
accept the offic
recommendation no making a proposal
yes proposal to approve
yes
recommendation have a second C Brandon
you want to speak now
or anybody want to make any more
comments
councelor Wyman go on thank you chair I
mean nothing could with what council al
already said really it was clearly um
we're in business to attract tourism
vibrant economy you know make the
district work um but there are so many
questions associated with the occupancy
of the of the existing structures along
with the application itself so you know
I would go along with that and recommend
refusal thank you anyone else Council
register
um I I would agree with councelor Holt
and councelor Wyman um having been to
the site I just looked at it and thought
this is a park home site with and
they're just making out out tourist I
thought some of the places looked
semi-permanent um to the extent that
they had their own ornaments and I said
garden gnomes but I'm sure there were
some um yeah I I I don't by their
business case uh I think yeah it needs
to be
refused thank you any more
comments councilor
Osborne thank you Mr chairman yes I've
um listened to uh councelor Ward and and
the uh Parish Council and and the
objector and am I correct in uh hearing
that uh two of those properties are for
sale that are supposed to be
uh well in my opinion they're not
proposing to
uh have Holiday Homes are they thank you
Mr
chairman thank
you anybody else want make any
comments C grandon you're going to
conclude
or um well if I may thank you
um I I did go inside one of the um
Holiday Homes and I thought they were
very attractive
accommodation and we do need holiday
accommodation however for me one of the
big problems is the scale of this
application and
um when you were on the site and also
seeing the plans that we saw before us
this morning
it almost felt like a a smaller State um
developing and um it it the the balance
of golf club versus um a small housing
estate came into play for me um as well
as all the the natural um aspects of
being in the
countryside um it almost wouldn't be in
the countryside
anymore um especially if there are
possibly some
long-term holiday makers present so I I
do feel that this is one that we have to
go with the officer's decision to refuse
unfortunately although I understand the
economic um problems of the
applicant thank
you thank you
there's no more comments other than my
own to say I agree with you all and can
I ask the CLA to conduct the
vote I just confirm the reasons for
refusal chairman May um you will because
you're going to include a yeah members
is as per the committee report on pages
81 to
82 um added to which um is the item of
biodiversity net gain the lack of which
is on your table paper as per our policy
lp16 and added to that any other reasons
which the chief planning officer
consider as expedient and that's not
just a a blank canvas we're just going
to flesh out one or two the other
reasons
basically
okay okay members that vote is now in
progress just to remind you a vote for
is a vote for refusal and against is a
vote against refusal so if you want
can yours not go through counselor
no I'll take it
verbally y for refusal okay thank you
chair there are eight members left and
that is eight votes for refusal
therefore that is carried thank you
thank
you um the next meeting is scheduled for
24th the 10th of January
2024 yes and we'll see you then I hope
everybody can stay for that one um I
will now formally close the
meeting